the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
world class play was on display at the
feed a candidates in madrid spain the
arduous journey to becoming the
challenger continues as players settled
in for the marathon event ian naponiacci
and fabiano caruana maintained control
of their shared lead after drawing their
intense match-up with the rest of the
field following suit
all except american hikaru nakamura who
defeated timor rajaba for the lone
victory of the day round three of
incredible chess
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody it is time for round
three in madrid spade where we are
playing the 2022 candidates tournament
to determine the challenger to the world
champion magnus carlson to bring you all
of the action we're here in our studio
in st louis i have grand master
alejandro ramirez with my good friend
grandmaster yasser sarawan alejandro
it's been great working with you and
christian calling all the action and two
words fighting chess absolutely we've
had scintillating couple of rounds
despite the fact that we've had only
three decisive games it feels like every
single game we've seen so far all eight
of them have been a great fight going
all the way to the end absolutely hello
everyone thank you for joining us
joining with us and sharing your day
i have to say that yesterday i saw
something phenomenal the grits
and determination of hikaru to grind
down
timor was just breathtaking is an
extraordinary game of great fighting
chess and that's what it's been let's
take a look at our current standings and
how they got here we've had three
decisive games in this tournament so far
two of them gave me the first round
where fabiano carrana and yana pomnyacci
started with victories they played each
other yesterday and now they sit pretty
at the top one and a half points for
each yeah she shall do that richard
rapport and the rest of perugia and now
hikaru nakamura are all sitting on fifty
percent hikaru having lost his first
game and coming back brilliantly against
steven rajab of yesterday meanwhile the
azeri player is with the chinese player
ding loren on only half a point out of
two and how did they get here let's
review uh the yesterday's matchup
absolutely classical chess here for you
guys it's only been a few games between
them and yesterday it was really a
missed chance wow by the hungarian
player richard rapport as alireza furuja
seemed to be in the verge of equalizing
but did not play the end game properly
and kept giving richard chances but they
were taken no and a big miss by richie
and then the game i mentioned hikaru
nakamura he seemed to get a an edge out
of the opening with this queen h5 move
that really got us all excited but it
was all about technique and he just he
just kept finding these incredibly
difficult moves moves that we were
struggling with throughout yesterday's
matches by the way which is so difficult
to call that he finally got the point
and climbs back to 50 percent yes and in
the important match between yesterday's
leaders
played a extremely sharp yoko piano i
think we're gonna have to get rid of
that name for the italian very soon
because it was not a quiet game not
quite an image not slow at all it was a
scintillating fight in which fabi
with very few minutes on the clock
decided to go for a repetition in a
position where maybe he could have tried
four more exactly exactly so but a great
uh game between our two leaders and then
our final game it was a game that was
confusing to us but it was also
confusing to do that he was unhappy with
his preparation he said that it landed
him in a spot that he did not understand
and it seemed that he was unable to
break through as dingler and simply set
up a nice fortress with his pawns and
duda could not do anything against it
and there you have it of the
of yesterday's game and our format uh we
have a very very long tournament for you
guys it's an eight player double round
robin that means that it's 14 rounds of
chess we are
very far from even being halfway through
classical chess in the longest format of
any tournament that's still standing 120
minutes for the first 40 moves 60
minutes once you reach move 40. once you
reach move 60 guess what you get another
15 minutes and you start taking your 30
second increment on each and every
single move afterwards no draws before
uh the 40th move and a half a million
dollar prize
yeah
and our schedule our pace is the same
throughout alejandro absolutely it's
three rounds and the rest day three
rounds and the rest the end because we
are on round number three tomorrow
monday june 20th we will have our first
rest day
and and uh christian you're with us good
morning my friend and you're gonna tell
us the odds of these players going
forwards
good morning yasser good morning
alejandro and good morning to every
chess fan around the world watching this
amazing event
as we are gearing up to start round
number three i want to take a look at
the odds of these players to win the
event and let's take a look how these
players went into the event as we can
see we have a clear leader that is
dingley ren the rating favorite
29.4 percentage points to win the event
almost a third to win the event alireza
firouza 20.7 and we see fabiano caruana
with 15.5 and yeah nepalnyashi the
previous challenger with 9.1 at the
bottom you see timur ajaba with only 3.7
percentage points but where do we stand
after round number one we know we had
two victors that is fabiano caruana and
jan nepomnyashi who showed scintillating
chess in round number one incredible
victories and that allowed them to surge
through the rankings of the oddsmakers
28.1 percentage points for fabiano
carguana 22.3
for yon nepomnyashi and look at hikaru
nakamura after losing his first round he
only sits at 2.8 percentage points by
the odds maker to win this event and
where do we stand after round number two
well still two clear leaders that is
fabiano caruana 29.1 percent and young
nepal nyashi but we see fabiano actually
increased by one percentage point you
might ask why does uh what does that
mean why did that happen because he only
drew against gyane ponnayashi well yes
he drew but he drew with the black
pieces so that definitely helps his case
and as we can see hikaru increased his
chances as well after bouncing back with
a beautiful victory against timur rajaba
we have an exciting event on our hands
and round three is about to start all
right we'll do the honors won't you
alejandro and what are our pairings
let's take a look at the third round
yesterday we have incredible matches for
you
dingley red with the white pieces we're
playing is richard rapport fabiano
carrano with white
will be playing against jan shisht of
duda that's going to be a key matchup in
my opinion
rajabov will be trying to bounce back
into this tournament as he has his white
pieces against jan nepomniacci and in my
personal view a game that i'm super
excited about alirez and kurusha for the
first time will be playing over the
board chess against ikaro nakamura in
classical so this is going to be an
absolutely breathtaking game alireza
started with two blocks in this
tournament finally gets a white two
great fighters that could very well be
our marquee match up and again what are
they fighting for in terms of money
alejandro it's a half million euro prize
pool and you can see their first place
is 48 000 of them and you get an extra 7
000 euros for every single full point
that you get right so that's a lot of
money but that's not even what they're
playing for they're playing for the top
prize that is a direct invite to play
world champion magnus carlson in the
next match 2023 location to be
determined but that's going to be at
least a 2 million euro match wow that's
just a lot of money that is just a lot
of money and that's what they're
fighting for is to become challenger it
was and here were our pre-tournament
predictions i wasn't looking at your
odds when i chose uh hikaru christian
i'm i'm looking good var is looking good
i don't know about you alejandro ding
you started off uh well well before the
first round unfortunately for you that
first round was uh quite difficult to
handle but it was he handled it well
with the black pieces against jan
shishtav duda in the second round he was
under some pressure and you could have
easily seen that game going yanshi
stuffs away fortunately for uh dinky
manage to start a ship and make a draw i
think an important draw and an important
boost of confidence for the young
chinese player
odds aside forget about the odds for a
moment two two games in the books who is
the happiest
of the eight players and who is the most
miserable
i think the most miserable is uh
it's pretty clear it has to be dingler
and it has to be it has to be he's
sitting at the bottom of the table and
comes in his pre-tournament favorite
he's the one that has the most pressure
on him uh if you see the top of the
table you already see fabiana karan and
jane and pommy actually who are
obviously sitting pretty happy not just
because of the results but i think their
play has also been very good but they
already won this tournament they already
know how it feels to be uh challenging
to be a challenger they've at least can
say that they've done it right whereas
dingley ran it really does feel that
he's due and he might be feeling
the way that levon i feel felt for a lot
of the candidates that everybody's
saying when is the match when is the
match carlos and aronia going to happen
it's never happened it never happened
and aronian has actually dropped out of
the cycle uh he didn't make it this year
right didn't make it to the candidate i
think dingle in the back of his mind he
must be thinking hey how many more
cycles do i have right and how can i be
spoiling my whites on the very first
round
in such an important tournament well the
good news for ding and the previous
candidates he started with two losses
so at least you know it's not really
it's an improvement yeah of those
players who have a 50 score yes put
yourself in richard's shoes yesterday he
comes back to lubo and lubo said you
know you missed a win here you missed a
win there and you missed a win there how
do you feel after that it's kind of
difficult for me to say because both
games even though he has obtained half a
point from them he did it in such
different ways right the first game that
he played in this tournament he was
against duda he survived by a miracle
yeah and yesterday it did feel that he
should have converted against garuja and
the thing about richard is that i feel
this both of these games exposed
weaknesses of him not able to convert
and bad opening preparation and it's
things that he needs to fix already if
he wants to actually win this tournament
and in the kind of a strange case of the
deja vu there richard played black
pieces and white pieces and in both
games featured c4c5
to break up the queenside pawn structure
as round three is underway i see the
first move of ding lorin now dinglerin
played c4 in the english
against nepo
well
d2d4
of that right no more that d2d4
richard uh one of those marvelously
creative players very very hard to
predict what defense he's going to try
go ahead and give it a shot he's such a
wild card
come on give it a shot king's indian
let's go kingston
christian what what what do you got for
us
he's going to go with the names
nimzo he has to go with something more
tape dude he's from hungary budapest i
understand the budapest gambit let's go
he's never going to play the budapest
gambit come on
okay knight f6
we're all right at the moment we were
asked yesterday a very nice question by
the audience and remember that you can
join the conversation we are on social
media we're on youtube we're on twitch
uh hashtag or at st louis chess club on
twitter so please join our conversation
here and we were asked yesterday yes how
has the ai changed or the neural
networks actually changed some openings
okay which i thought was a very very
smart question
which ones have gotten into fashion and
have become acceptable and which ones
were just out of the book right budapest
gambit absolute trash
really got trash trash trash every line
oh no and if you if you want to look at
the
by the way
g6
could be grunfeld could be kings indian
come on baby yeah make me write for once
and we're about to find out we're about
to find out this is the bishop g7 or d5
d5 is the groomful by the way i do i
have it right in thinking that ding
loren is like the king's indian
defense slayer yeah he's done very good
some
really awesome uh victories uh against
the he's done some amazing work with
both colors uh group but we do have the
groomfeld yeah and yeah now it's quite
not expecting the process it survived
barely uh against sting lyran playing
the kings in in that not many players
have the groom felt these seventies have
you ever played the groom fight i
haven't don't remember richard playing
cruz no no he's not a gruffalo bishop g7
e4 d7 d6 starting position of the king's
indian it was a favorite of gary
kasparov bobby fisher as well as others
d75 also a favorite of gary caspar all
right mvl and many others you were about
to say that
richard dabbling in something very very
different from his normal repertoire
i do not know him as a
groomfield player
at least not that i can remember he's a
very difficult uh player to uh spot now
one thing about the grunfeld does any of
the players actually play the groom fell
yes nepo in this field he used to play
the opposite but i don't think he plays
it anymore fabiano used to play the
grunfeld he grew up with that was a long
time ago he made his 2750 with a
groomfield but after that he dropped it
off his repertoire none of the players
currently have the groomfeld in their
repertoire so when you prepare for this
type of event you know as richie rapport
he's been playing a lot you don't have a
lot of seconds either because this is
one of the things that he was
complaining the fact that he's not
getting a lot of support uh and right
now you're thinking these players have
had
a year a year and a half to prepare for
this tournament
they specifically are preparing for
certain players and their repertoires
but none of them are playing the
grunfeld why wouldn't i play the
grunfeld and surprise them because we
know probably ding has spent a lot of
time on the kings indian hikaru has
spent a lot of time on the name so
exactly but probably he hasn't spent
that much time on the grunfeld and i
think this is quite an interesting
surprise by rigid report wow well we'll
definitely keep an eye on this one let's
just go around the horn
and jump into uh one of the games
of our leaders just a second how come
that didn't come up what do you mean
they did bobby yeah did come up favi
versus duda e4 we have an open sicilian
alejandro
i'm a little surprised about the opening
choices today i'm not going to lie
english the sicilian attack
the english attack this is part of
fabi's repertoire he's played both
bishop g5 and bishop e3 very
successfully just dabbled on other
variations like h3 and pretty much
everything else bishop g5 i remember a
game he had against ikaru that was he
sacrificed his queen and the mvl game oh
that was just so much fun uh bishop e3
uh that's a completely different
uh line of the english attack f3
and the players very quickly explain as
they move h7 h5 i know it's a very
standard move but it sure looks like
you're wasting an entire tempo to stop
g2 g4 and it's become fashionable to
play the move h5 whether it's this move
or the next one
just to stop the move g4 g5 from coming
and it is white's main plan to go queen
d2 long castle and play g4 in one
sequence of moves or the other this is
of course a little uh simplified
there's a lot of subtle differences
between playing h5 first not playing h5
first here usually the bishop actually
goes on on g7
in many variations
actually the move g6 i think is quite
popular bishop e7 is popular rook c8 is
popular uh but
it does
change the character of the position
it goes from a very direct knight or for
white ghost g4 black goes b5 and let's
see who kills each other first yes
uh this one is a little more positional
okay you force white to slow down the
attack uh h3 doesn't actually threaten
g4 no and can always be met later by the
move h4 by black so there's no easy way
to get the move g4 in on the king side
which means that white usually actually
spends a lot of tempe on the queen side
to the to the point and to the degree
where the move b5 in many cases actually
becomes a positional mistake
not necessarily right away but in many
cases you give up the a5 square even
give up the c4 break of playing the move
95 and following it up with the move c4
so you have to know your positions quite
well it's easy to fall into deep trouble
very quickly
if you don't know what you're doing
especially after the move h5
right h7h5 one of those moves that kind
of dissuades you from wanting to castle
kingside
no this by the way is going to be a game
an excellent game
yeah also
just a little inside note that i'm
confused about the opening choices so
far radport is not a groomful play and
even though duda does play the night off
okay i don't think that he has the best
results with him i never felt that the
night or was really good
he's fit i particularly was shocked by
his handling of the night or in last
year's prague invitational was just
finished this year's edition just
finished yes uh which was won last year
by uh former u.s champion sam shanklin
right and sam shanklin's path to victory
including crushing duda from the night
or i mean
sam didn't think
he just crushed him out of the opening
with preparation
and i wanted to see duda come with good
ideas and proper preparation the night
of let's see how he's been able to fix
all of those holes uh in this year in
the meantime let's uh turn it over to
christian
and ask him to take us through a game
that he's been keeping his eyes on
christian what do you have for us well
i'm i'm i'm looking at the grunfeld game
of course i love the groomfell i'm a
greenfield player myself and i really
want to see what this elite level
players are going to be uh bringing to
the table today especially a novel
groomfeld player that is a reachy
rapport because whenever you start
playing a new opening you have fresh
ideas you have an enthusiasm that you
cannot really find five ten years into
your greenfield career and this is
exactly what i want to see from these
players today knight two knight to c6 we
see this bishop to c4 knight to e2 idea
we've seen dingley ran as it uh in uh
previous cycles i think he played it
even even in the candidates if not him
it was van gaal against uh maxim vashir
lagrav this was quite popular this
bishop to c4 knight to e2 so i'm sure
richie was quite well prepared against
this bishop to e3 castle castle and now
black has a lot of options one of the
main options is to go bishop to g4 and
this was the main line for a very long
time usually of course you have to
respond with f3 otherwise you're going
to lose upon bishop take c2 take on d4
take on d4
and i'm going to have more attackers
than you have defenders so you have to
play f3 cut the action of the bishop on
g4 once again black has a couple of ways
of approaching this position if you want
to avoid the forced lines you're just
simply going to go bishop to d7 and this
is something that i always played uh
because i'm just lazy to learn first
line so i was just playing bishop to d7
hoping that i'm not going to get
checkmated slow play queen to c7 later
on rook fda kc8 e6 and just play a
normal game unfortunately it does seem
like this particular setup does allow
white to get an advantage slow play
advantage requiem to uh d2 rook to c1
rook to d1 and at some point you're
going to have enough space on the king
side to create some problems you're
going to go f4 f5 maybe knight to f4 to
follow it up and it's going to be quite
difficult for black to find its counter
chances now he decided against this and
he decided to go for a much more uh
modern approach let's say instead of
bishop to g4 he started off with b6
this b6 move came into fashion just a
couple of years ago maybe three four
years ago two three four years ago
something along those lines and we've
seen quite a lot of high level games in
this one one that i particularly
remember was um a beatdown of maxim
vacher lagrav by sergey karjakin because
maxim who is an expert and he only plays
the grunfeld forgot his theory at move
25 i think so it was something just
ridiculous he forgot that he has to
include a certain move in uh the
position and he just got the worst
position lost without much chances a b6
defending the pawn on c5 now the paradox
about the position is that actually you
defend it upon c5 but once white takes
on c5 you're not actually going to
recapture uh immediately you're actually
going to try to focus on the action that
you're getting on the c file with uh the
elimination of this pawn on c5 now
after a b6 the take c5 is one of the
main lines as well he played the move
rook to c1 and now immediately we see
the move a bishop to b7 by richie
rapport of course this knight is going
to most likely come to a5 open up the
bishop create some tension in the center
as it is and then continue once again
with normal developing play queen to c7
this rook comes in the center and the
middle game is going to develop in the
next couple of moves we're going to find
out what the exact plans of these
players are in the next few moves so
let's wait and see let's let the players
surprise each other because we know rich
rapport probably surprised thing first
but now let's see what ding has in store
for richie and he's playing quite fast
as well he got surprised at the
beginning he spent some time trying to
figure out uh what his preparation was
and this is exactly what we're seeing
right now this is the battle that is
ongoing bishop to b5 was played right
now richie taking his first thing still
within the throes of theory rook to c8
seems to be the main line just normal
play let's see where that takes us thank
you christian uh for me a game that is
absolutely confounding
most of my career i was playing the
white side of the nimzo indian the
classical variation with queen c2
and today's engines as you have said are
very very impactful
on this particular line and the players
are doing some really strange things
as white so we have this move b7 b6 all
theory everything's fine
but you know you kind of notice that all
of white's pieces are still on the first
rank you know you got to get these guys
into the game and you you kind of think
to yourself
that uh
that should be uh what you need to do i
think it was actually knight f3 bishop
a6
queen a4 and then gary kasparov played
h4 no it was without the knight on f3
what's with the rook d1 was it also with
rook d1 rook d1 on the board bishop a6
queen a4 i think aaron is playing the
queen to c2 uh which does change the
well that's what i was about to say
because the queen actually after this
mcqueen e7 knight f3 rook d8 so again
i'm thinking you know you gotta
rush
and complete your development
actually yeah help me what well the game
really revolves around one thing it's
the c5 break uh you want to make the c5
break as uncomfortable as possible
yeah
whether it's because you take and you
can take on f6 or because you can take
and force an isolated pawn on c5 right
you're trying to get some kind of
position in which you have a long term
positional pressure either against a
backward pawn on c7 or a potentially
isolated pawn on c5 this is pretty much
what it all comes down to and the
question
in which will be in black's chord
is not well in the current position this
is all quite i wanted to ask why if you
thought the queen was better placed on
c2 why don't you just put it there right
away though you can you can put it on c2
right away the issue is that on c2 it
doesn't attack the bishop on a6 so it
gives me the extra option of the move
knight bd7 gotcha whereas in the current
position black has already spent the
tempos with queen e7 rook d8 and after
the move queen c2 you probably don't
really want to play knight bd7 now that
you put all of your pieces on this
diagonal
because after queen c2 you are you are
kind of threatening uh
the move e4
again it'll challenge black do you
really want to play g5 and sometimes
this sacrifice on g5 actually works now
i i have looked specifically at this
position i'm told by the way that queen
c2 in our million plus database of games
is actually a rare bird only twice
yes but everybody's looking at this line
right uh it's aligned that's where i'm
i'm preparing i'm coming to these
candidates and your
christian was talking about well what do
you prepare for well the funny thing is
that
i don't think that anybody's preparing
it for these candidates because this
this had the um
i'm not going to say it was worked out
but it was pretty close it was pretty
close to worked out this variation i
mean i was looking at this in 2018 when
i was preparing favi
and we didn't feel that there was any
problems that black does have to
remember a few important details here
and there um you do have to remember the
difference between playing c5 here and
ipd7 there like when do you play c5
because you as we saw there's queen a4
queen c2 there's queen c2 directly
there's a3 there's e4 so there's a lot
of different ways where white can try to
put the pressure
but so many games especially hikaru
games right ended in quick draws i think
hikaru proved this to be equal against
mamadiarov twice right and then then the
variation disappeared right so hikar has
been a a player of the nimzo india
specifically this variation forever and
i want to see exactly what ferruja has
in mind now i gave a very big speech
about all this and now what is very good
speech thank you what was what is the
actual move in this position right right
and if i remember correctly it's c5 and
it does go into incredible complications
like incredible complications you do not
take on c5 because in this particular
version you take on d1 queen takes one
and you have to think with the queen and
you say haha i don't care about my pawn
knight c6 rook did and you start trying
to checkmate white because
yeah
yeah all the pieces there i say once
more are still on the first rank right
so the line actually goes uh c5 e4
okay
i know that we don't have any games but
i i have looked at this position
you want to trade you take on f1 uh i
think it's uh i think you think about
the rook okay i don't remember you think
with the rook with the king you go g5
now now the threat of course is e5 and
your exploit the pin so yeah you have to
play the only move is g5 you take on g5
it's the only move excuse me yeah you
take on g5 is the only move you take on
g5 is the only move bishop takes g5 is
the only move knight bd7 is the only
actually i don't remember if knight bd7
was the only move i think you could take
on d4 it doesn't matter uh e5 doesn't
work because f4 i think whatever okay uh
e5 okay c takes
yeah and this is supposed to be equal
because after pawn takes f6 there's
queen c5 so all of this has been like
worked out ish wow even i know this so
and this isn't even your reputation and
this is not even in my repertoire it's
just that everybody's playing
this line so i i i took a look at it uh
i'm wondering where are they reza is
going to bring
a new idea yeah i think somewhere there
it's already a novelty right it's one of
those things that
has a top chess grand master which i am
not but i am preparing some of them
you kind of
know that it's a novelty but that
everybody knows that novelty right right
that everybody is looking at yeah yeah
nobody's played it nobody's played it
but everybody knows it they're like five
moves beyond it yeah exactly because
it's a sharp line and it's very forcing
so it feels like everybody has been
looking at this line i want to know
where uh ferruccio is going to be
deviating and i think that this is a
position with ricardo's is not actually
thinking
he's kind of trying to be clever he's
trying to remember his lines he's trying
to figure out where is my opponent's
trap i'm playing a young hungry player
at the candidates 19 years of age he's
not making a quick draw he's not going
to give me quality from the opening no
where is he going to test me so he kind
of smelling a fish
and he wants to see where it is exactly
because the move g5 and knight takes g5
was a little a little bit surprising can
i
uh switch hikaru's move order if you
don't mind yes i start with g5 and then
you go bishop g3 c5 yeah
and then you get hit by h4 and the point
is that on h4 yes it's either h4 or 95 i
actually don't remember that okay
h4 g4 okay and then knight e5 and then
the position is actually not so clear
again it's a complete it's a complete
mess there's rook takes d4 there's c
takes d4
it's a humongous mess this one guy's
still on the first range and this one is
incredibly playable for both sides okay
but i wasn't entirely sure
if uh on sacrifice yeah i'm not i wasn't
sure if black's okay whereas in the
other line it felt
with the queen's ic5 the black was doing
fine yeah wow uh
high
level falutin
theory that we've been uh looking at and
you're welcome to join our conversation
christian
uh jumping back to you what about our
other game
of our tournament leader jan
and i have to say guys first of all i'm
appreciative to the players that they're
just bringing it every single day they
are bringing it white black doesn't
really matter what color you have you're
coming here for a fight you don't want
to make an easy draw we haven't seen the
petrov
we haven't seen well we've seen the
burden but it actually took two hits so
i don't know how many more
we're going to go
the two berlins have lost already he
carved one and hikaru lost with a berlin
so actually we don't see the typical
drawing alliance that we usually get now
we see the najdorf we see the groomfeld
we see these battles and i'm really
enjoying all the games because of that
now we see yan shishtav do the essaying
the naidorf right you're playing against
fabiano caruana you probably you've seen
what happened to the other two guys at
the beginning of the tournament they've
been out prepared so you're trying to
surprise first this is what i think uh
was the thought process of jan shishtav
duda going into this game he wanted to
surprise his opponent first nevertheless
it does seem at this point one hour 56
minutes for fabiano so he was more or
less blessing out his moves and do that
only with one hour and 48 so it does
seem like you tried to surprise your
opponent it was actually fabiano who uh
managed to a surprise and show his
better preparation now let's see what
happened
duda played this move b5 and right now
white has um
an array of options now h3 is one of
them preparing the move f4 generally
when you see the move h5 you're not
necessarily going to focus on a g4 you
are going to tease your opponent maybe i
will play g4 but i have to prepare that
because of course after g4 take take the
rook on h1 is hanging so first of all
after a move such as queen to c7 now i
go bishop to d3 opening up the
connection between the rooks and now g4
is a real threat if i manage to go g4
put some pressure on your king side then
your king becomes extremely extremely
weak also g5 is coming your knight gets
destabilized you don't want to allow
that so generally black responds with
the move h4 blocking the situation on
this side as it is for these two pawns
but
also this move h3 allows me to play f4
and not have to worry about the move
knight to g4 so f4 generally is the
continuation here once again i'm trying
to create tension in the center as well
as a little bit on the kingside f5
potentially or take on e5 are two
options later on in the game but instead
of that
fabiano not h3 not some slow play knight
d5 directly that is uh in fact one of
the more topical lines asking an
immediate question which piece are you
going to use
to capture on the fight and transition
into a new structure because right now
white has a clear idea that is knight
takes e7 i pick up the bishop and then i
pick up the pawn on this six so you
don't have time to just play castle for
example because now you're just simply
completely lost pawn down no bishop
error for you and you can basically
resign so you're forced to take on d5
now recently it was uh this game between
if i'm not mistaken aronian and van
forest
with the move knight takes d5 and it was
played um in october
2021 the problem with knight xd5 is that
after bishop to f5 knight to a5
you're in big trouble with black this
knight is landing to c6 you don't have
the knight on f6 to try to create
pressure on the d5 pawn and this is the
key aspect and the key factor in the
assessment of this position if you don't
manage to attack the pawn on d5
and make my knight on c6 uncomfortable
because that knight is landing on c6
after this move knight to a5 and this is
another consequence of the move knight
to d5 opening up the support of the
queen from d2 to a5 so i really like
this i don't know what van forest was
thinking when he took with the knight
because this position is already in
shambles for black so
what he should be doing and what duda
did actually is bishop takes d5
switching
the pieces uh which one to capture on d5
with it xd5 knight to b6 as we were
discussing putting immediate pressure on
this pawn d5 and right now big moment
there are two options bishop takes b6 is
the obvious one to defend uh the pawn on
d5 by eliminating one of the attackers
that
gives up the dark square bishop and we
see the usual presence of the opposite
color bishops
after bishop takes b6 queen takes b6 we
get these positions in which white will
have a beautiful square on c6 the
problem is as soon as you land there
knight takes d5 is going to be a
tactical motif allowing you to take on
d5 and then the knight on c6 will be
hanging so you have to be careful how
you do that that another option for
white is to try to push uh his pawns on
the king side knight to a5 followed by
c4 and trying to create some tension
like that that's one way to approach
this position and right now fabiano by
the way after knight to b6 is thinking
because the other way is actually to go
knight to a5 and just sacrifice a pawn
you are giving up upon i understand that
but
after bishop takes b6
knight has to take back on b6 you cannot
take with the queen anymore because
after queen to d5 i understand you can
take my knight on a5 but you still have
a rook hanging you cannot go there you
cannot allow that so after knight takes
d5
waiting one move to take on b6 forces
the knight to go to b6 and now we get
this position after c4 and we were
discussing about uh the presence of the
opposite color bishops what does that
entail so let's say something along this
line so i understand black
is
up upon right
but the biggest factor of assessment in
positions with opposite color bishops is
who has the active bishop as well as who
has the initiative and in this position
right now it does feel like white has
tremendous initiative where are you
going to put the king is the big
question for black are you going to go
on the queen side absolutely not you're
not allowed to go there because you're
going to get checkmated are you going to
go on the
on the king side sure probably you will
but then that's going to open up the
question of how i'm going to hook you
and now we see
what the consequence of this move h7 to
h5 is going to be long term because
that's a hook and i'm going to hook it
i'm going to go h4 first stabilize the
pawn on h5 and then follow it up with g4
that's going to create tremendous
pressure on black skin and despite the
extra pawn i generally tend to
approach this position as better and
assess it as better for white guys what
do you think i'm trying to remember a
game
alejandro uh between linear dominguez
and mbl that was very similar to this
sinkhole cup of 2021. it was brilliant
right so really we gave it a brilliancy
price exactly exactly it was so good uh
is that uh
the same line or is it just a little bit
something similar it's very similar but
it's not exactly let me just go if you
don't go to the night earth game i'll
tell you where the deviation
is we can look at it in your board all
right we're talking about a great game
uh between linear dominguez and a maxima
sherlock graph which
was absolutely scintillating to us and
we're going to see the difference in
handling of the united st you actually
have to go all the way back
uh before the move h5 because h5 was not
played in that game okay uh the ideas
are very similar so we will actually
take a look at them but
after bishop e3 how did the game
continue yeah the bishop e3 the game
continued let me go all the way there
bishop e3 bishop
e7 bishop b7 so mbl did not play did not
play him at all okay queen d2 okay
knight bd7
castle long castle short
okay
g4 b5 and this is the difference right
right why didn't you get in g4 but black
gets in g5 uh b5 sorry the same kind of
ideas though d5 is weak and the knights
do start hopping around here you remove
the knight from f6 first you go g5 i see
knight h5
knight uh d5
sorry sorry king b1 first i apologize
okay knight d5 knight d5 is another line
but knight h5 king b1 okay knight b6
and here we get into the positions that
we want to look at knight a5 was played
in that game
rook c8 okay
knight d5
and now knight takes works and was
played in the game
pawn takes bishop
takes queen takes
queen takes a5 and queen takes a5 and
eventually this knight on h5 traded
itself for the bishop on
on e3 by playing knight f4 it actually
happened quickly c4 94
the crazy part about this game as it
unfolded
was the fact that it was still in the
throes of things it was still in the
throes of theory right right so this is
all well known by this point not only is
the mvl uh game there there were other
games that were played in this exact
position and this was the bishops of
opposite color middle game that we're
looking at with christian exactly ops
the same kind of idea different move
order different exact positions
subtleties are different you got an h5
and it's not on g5 right lots of
different things compared to one game
from another but again we've said this
in the broadcast a lot
grand masters love comparing and
contrasting different games absolutely
and trying to figure out which version
is better for them right and in this one
the opposite color bishops still have
the same spirit you have the initiative
with white but you're down upon can your
attack break through uh basically it
comes down to tempe exactly and i just
remembered that that was such a
wonderful
wonderful game by linear i mean we were
just
breathless as we watched it unfold it
was great and uh well fabi
uh
let's go back excuse me i'm just gonna
refresh my board uh could be getting
into those types of middle games with
the knight coming and to play c4
uh he didn't
by the way sacrifice the d5 pawn as
christian was mentioning that
he immediately took on v6
is the point there
um i just wanted to say about the game
of ian and timor
again the fashion of theory it's very
very hard the catalan has been popular
for
decades i mean just decades decades
knight c6
and in my time
the move d4 takes c5 was frowned upon
they just thought that this ending was
too even
and that the best or most challenging
line of play was actually queen a4 and i
must have spent a summer
on this queen sacrifice i don't know if
you're
if you're aware of this queen sacrifice
but uh it was a game between gary
kasparov and old anderson off anderson
was on the black side
and i was trying to understand
this position at the end of the day
black has a bishop rook and pawn
but a really really good bishop on c6
like that bishop on g2 is crying you
know you don't have the bishop on g2 the
game that i sided between gary and olf
was drawn but this is where
everybody you was chasing you know like
there's a line of people trying to
understand this queen sacrifice now
i i don't know is it is it an engine uh
d4 takes c5 this has become the most
topical yeah queen a4 is also aligned
but it's
white's not finding an advantage as well
as knight a three two pardon
also knight a3 is also very popular no
nobody with black is entering the the
queen sacrifice the queen sacrifice
considered to be bad theoretically uh
white is just better in that end game
because you have more development
in which enemy and i'm sorry the the
queen sacrifice you showed me yes yeah
that's bad for black yes it is bad now
so nobody's looking at it
i mean a misspent youth yeah
knight d2 c3 i feel like i've seen uh
wesley so uh quite a number of games
again my mind kind of turns to mush
in these variations but it just feels
like uh
after bishop d7 black is
basically happy i mean everybody's
playing this line with the black pieces
not nepo nepo is the type of catalan
player that was playing the more
aggressive b5 lines he even played it in
the world championship match right so
perhaps a small surprise for a java that
nepo is going for the let's say dryer
yes c5 variations right that being said
if you're a catalan player this is a
topical line right now as you mentioned
everybody's playing it specifically
wesley and levon neronian right both
with white and black have been trying to
gain an advantage with white draw this
with black successfully they win it with
white and they draw with black but
i don't feel that theoretically right
now this is giving white very much it's
very very dry it's very much in rajab of
style to play this very safe extremely
safe sometimes you could argue two safe
rides sometimes you just need to take a
little a little risk yeah
from nepal's point of view a comfy
equality just what the doctor ordered
we'll take a look right this is
still a battle uh it feels by the time
situation that it's nepal that's clearly
the one enjoying his position more that
he's had it before the tournament
started or before the round started uh
tons of games still to be played i want
to see where we deviate and we actually
finally get the game going because
there's been so many dozens of games
from this position already that we
cannot really add anything new just yet
exactly we're still very far from
stopping theory exactly all right well
we'll we'll let this uh percolate well
let's go to let's go to christian let's
see what he has for us sure
well one thing that we always focus on
uh guys is the opening phase uh and we
tend to do that because the opening
phase is so important for the trajectory
of the game not necessarily the final
result but the trajectory of the game
whoever wins the opening battle is going
to dictate where the game is going to go
and we've seen hikaru nakamura for
example in the first round against
fabiano caruana he was the one under
tremendous pressure from the opening
face he managed to steer the ship and
actually got a very decent position
maybe even a better position at what
point unfortunately for him he went on
to lose that game in the second round
against timur rajabov he was the one
surprising his opponent and getting an
advantage out of the opening and it was
timor who had to work very hard to
actually equalize the position
unfortunately for him his energy levels
weren't the same and this is why you
want to put pressure as soon as move one
on your opponent drain his energy levels
and this is exactly what we're seeing
right now from ali reza once again
hikaru is on the receiving end he got
surprised now
the squint way for queen to c2 is quite
an interesting approach quite a novel
approach as well only a couple of games
have been played and after the move c5
in fact only one game was played in the
database and that was with bishop takes
f6 which is not a good move you just
cannot give up your bishop pair just
like that with bishop takes f6 you have
to take advantage of this pin so the way
he did that and we know who's working
for uh firuja is one ivan chaparrinov
who is well known for his opening
preparation and theoretical knowledge
and also experience of working at the
highest level he worked with vaseline
topolo for a number of years when he was
one of the contenders as well as the
world champion now he came up with this
idea of uh e4 and he played it very very
quickly four minutes only uh down on his
clock one hour and 56 minutes and one
hour and 38 minutes for hikaru so he's
definitely
having uh spending a lot of time and
spending a lot of energy on trying to
understand the position and trying uh to
defend this very very difficult attack
that is coming with the move e4 followed
by e5 so bishop takes f1 was played now
white
g5
g5 first and this is what i wanted to
say
at this point if you don't play the move
g5 you're much worse it hurts but what
g5 invites is this sacrifice by the way
if you play the move bishop to g3 and
that's why i was getting excited because
i saw this move g5 and i saw that bishop
g3 doesn't really work because bishop g3
knight to c6 now black is the one that
actually has the initiative you don't
have the right to castle anymore you
cannot bring your pieces uh into play
you will have to go king to e2 to create
the connection between the rooks and you
don't want to see your king
there so after g5 white was forced and
he knew that to take on g5 take on g5
bishop takes g5 establish the connection
establish the pin now uh is going to be
very difficult since you don't have any
pawns to uh kick my bishop away and e5
is a big big threat and we've seen
knight to c6 immediately answered by
firuja not with e5 which would have uh
regained the peace but with the move
queen to c1
and this is probably going to come as a
shock to hikaru because right now he
knows
he had this position in uh his notes
hiruja that is he had it with his
seconds i'm under tremendous pressure
right now and i have to find a way and
the way i'm seeing it e5
i can continue with d5 and now we
understand what this rook on f1 is doing
as well why didn't he take with the king
on f1 well that's because after this e5
d5
couple of moves i'm going to have the
idea of playing the move f4 and opening
up the f file
this spin is going to be one that we're
going to watch very carefully because
right now if ikaru
misses a bit and makes one mistake he's
going to be in a big big trouble and
this is exactly the type of preparation
that we like to see and these players
like to engage with so
we're a little mystified though
christian because we looked at this
exact position and alejandro had pointed
out that the theory was knight on b8 to
d7
now the move e5
and in this case um you can't maybe but
not in not in this exactly no no
absolutely i'm not 100 sure it's 97 or
not but knight two six is also a move
okay yeah yeah and queen c5 and that
looked like it was solving black's
issues i i again we're gonna have to
wait for future theory because as far as
i know this is okay for blah blah knight
c6 is also good i actually know this
line queen c1 uh i think the move here
if i remember correctly is rook takes d4
okay and this is supposed to be a fourth
draw so again i want to know where
ferugia has a new idea okay you take you
take with the knight
i go e5 no e5 doesn't work and i forgot
why but the move is queen f4 i just want
to show you a pretty long queen b7 queen
e5 queen b7 and then you have 24 queen
takes g2 ideas i gotcha and we have
counterplay and queen f4 wins except for
one move
except for one move yeah i've had all of
this on my computer no way yeah it's
queen d7
queen b7 bdd queen davidson seven yeah
and if you take on uh f6 i just give you
a perpetual and you you could take on d4
but you're not better
wow and i can't avoid the perpetual yeah
you can't
this actually ends up uh i made it yeah
oh my goodness and if i go king d2 i
mean it looks like you're getting mated
on the king's side look at that bishop
on f6 that should terrify you
it's a draw it's a draw it's just a
worked out draw it's yeah okay i'll i'll
take that uh as
as gold if you will so i mean it was an
engine i didn't come up with any of this
you know that was actually a very nice
no it was queen b5 i'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah that's what it was
knight d4 back blue system let's go back
a couple of moves go back again i'll
just check rechecking with uh with an
actual engine so we go queen c1 yeah
it's rook takes d4 is correct rook takes
which is not the only move if i remember
correctly but i thought it was the
cleanest okay rook takes uh knight takes
d4 queen f4 queen d7 bishop f6
okay
right yeah so good knight c2 check
king e2 and then i apologize it's
actually uh queen b5 in this position
queen b5 in this position and you do
actually take that rook uh you go king
d2 right queen takes f1
no way yeah and you you just run away
from what looks like a complete mating
grip but it's not and it's not it's not
wow yeah because even if you play um
queen h6 how did it well then you take
on f2 yeah
yeah so this is what i think we're
probably going to see from furuja if
they are going into this line and it
very much matters whether hikaru
remembers everything or and not because
the line is extremely deep so as you
were mentioning alejandro and this
perhaps is the cleanest way queen to d7
place f6 knight to c2 and we have this
line right yeah
this one
is into g3 king to f8 everything is
forced you cannot go to h7 we've seen
this and you pick up
the pawn perhaps not the rook i don't
know i think if you take the rook
there's going to be some perpetual it
doesn't matter if you take an hour later
and then we're going to go into this
line
and maybe king to b5 as well king takes
c2 and how easy is this to navigate
because obviously you you're not going
to probably give me a perpetual right
now
you have to pick up some points because
if you don't then you're going to
connect the passwords and try and i
always have some checks coming your way
as white right queen to d7 is looking at
your king perhaps supported by a4 and
i'm not seeing a clear way of you
involving your rook uh into play right
every single square is protected this
bishop on f6 is doing that from the
computer
exactly rook f8 and you have to play
this type of moves and i think this is
going to be a longer game right and this
is where i think uh that ferugias
preparation actually starts
in this position at move
30. but the thing about this end game is
that if white doesn't hurry up and
actually you know produce the good
produce the goods you are down in
exchange and you do have four connected
past pawns but they they end up dropping
pretty quickly wow you can get two of
them but then i can two is a lot five h4
h5 and any sort of end game your rook is
actually going to be quite sterile i
don't um
rook takes d4 yes and you've been
showing some remarkable remarkable
variations but let's not forget
dude to piece up
at this exact moment
could you just i'm sure you will uh
having uh looked at this line could if i
were to play the move e6 e5 to stop you
from playing e5 is it
are you playing f4 or some crazy i'll be
quiet i'll be quite honest when i
prepare this line i
my the player that i was preparing for
only needed a draw
so we didn't actually look at the more
complicated lines and so you you wanted
to secure the drawer we just wanted to
secure the drawer right so e5 d5 a
knight d4 is a mess and i don't actually
remember the evaluation of it i know
that you can play rook d3 in this
position and then uh you have to move
the queen and go knight h7 not to get
mated and you don't get made it and you
have a beautiful night right but it's
still pretty dangerous
it is no no no question about it i i
feel that this could
this is a game you could easily lose
but
i'm a piece up and somehow sometimes you
just gotta ask your opponent uh
you know
is the sacrifice correct again it's so
forcing yeah and queen c1 is the top
engine move here so remarkable
i mean you kind of have to know it uh
guys but this is why i'm concerned right
you have to know it you've analyzed it
alejandro yesterday i don't
you've seen this maybe in your who knows
but you've seen this type of situation
in your analysis as well uh now the
question is how much of it does hikaru
remembers because you do have to
remember very precise moves if you once
again make a mistake make one inaccurate
move you lose instantaneously so this is
uh why i think of your russia's
preparation is quite inviting for a
mistake from hikaru and i'm concerned
about hikaru because he
is spending almost eight minutes after
this move queen to c1 and i'm sure he
knows that this move exists i'm sure
he's he knows he's seen this i'm sure he
knows that his second has analyzed and
gave him the notes and told him that
this is going to be an easy draw for you
but does he remember it this is the
question that he will have to answer
over the board with a lot of pressure on
his shoulders
alejandro hikara is very expressive
player i mean he will sit there and be
shaking his head as if he's
the greatest injustice
of all times has been perpetrated
against him how dare somebody make a
novelty again exactly and uh uh but do
you think that's just
acting
he's a very expressive person in general
it is a little annoying when he does it
over the board i'm not gonna lie i've
played hikaru right
many times i mean throughout the years
the first time we played we were like
11.
i'm not kidding
and he's always been like that he's
always been very expressive he you can
feel his emotions through the board the
way he puts his pieces on the board
right
um
it doesn't ever feel
like he's acting
it always feels like this is his name
this is me and i'm putting all of me
onto the board and on to my emotions
right and i never felt like he did it to
distract anybody or to be a bad sport or
anything like that no games mission no
games i always thought that it was just
who hikaru is he's an expressive person
who lets himself be an expressive person
on the board i feel that a lot of people
that are a lot more expressive outside
of the board
are very
calm during their games i've seen lots
of grandmasters that when you meet them
in real life and they're like they're
like a walking party right they're like
talking to everybody and they're
shouting and this but you see them on
the board and they're like cool come and
collect it right whereas i always felt
there were other players that
there were also
centers of attention and they showed it
over the board right gary was one oh boy
was another right and i don't feel i've
never felt that he did it to disrespect
anybody or as a showsman he just did it
because that's who he is okay very good
queen c1 a remarkable move
and you're saying rook takes d4 is the
cleanest and the most accurate way of
going by the way one line we didn't look
at
but you mentioned it i
meant to put it on the board and that
was the move e5
uh
later you were explaining that queen f4
was much more dangerous and in response
to e5 there was only one move and you
mentioned the move queen b7 i don't
remember if it was only one move i
remember this is good enough so that you
could just from this you cannot do at
all exactly yeah yeah you can come
happily uh to
e4 so
you know
i can understand anybody out there in
our audience thinking well i will play
e5 bishop takes f6 and give you
checkmate yep and e5 queen b7 will hurt
your feelings
right here
it's very strange i have this
deja vu we're talking about the other
day that i've seen this position being
played i looked at the database nobody's
ever played it which means that i
probably had this on the computer
somewhere somehow right but i remember
all of this like queen e4 you can't go
queen e3 because knight c2 you get mated
on d2 so you actually have to take with
something else and then queen
b7 you're actually losing with white
you're actually losing right yeah 27 is
just winning that's why you haven't seen
e5 right exactly and that was why queen
f4 became the main move i thought that i
i didn't complete either was uh this
swarmathon ananda in an interview on how
he prepares for his openings so he was
explaining uh that he gets an
inspiration about a certain line
and then he just puts it on fritz and
then he just goes to sleep
and he wakes up in the morning
and he just goes through
and it's like a spell checker a legal
move checker a tactical checker
and
it
the the engine says yeah this is a
really cool idea or no you're an idiot
it doesn't work and i thought that was
rather insightful that that's how
a five-time world champion prepares
well things have changed right right i i
think it's incredibly inefficient to run
engines
today throughout the night first of all
it doesn't really improve their strength
at all really yeah they look deeper and
another ply in another ply and doesn't
it change there are options yes there
are options that you can ask the
computer to actually create a tree of
what he's uh analyzing yeah so he goes
through the analysis by itself and it
creates a three and i would assume this
is what anand uh was specifically
thinking about and then he goes through
the three and then if he left lets it
for like a night then that's quite a lot
now i'm thinking about it mining bitcoin
it's quite energy consuming but how
about using engines uh for chess players
i'm pretty sure chess players overall
have used more energy than mining
it's quite a lot it's quite a lot
i burnt midnight oil sorry no i used a
lot of electricity
uh
late night uh analysis but those things
guys i just want to
drag your attention to this one because
it might finish quite quickly and this
is the game between team raj above and
young neph you are mentioning alejandro
that you're looking forward to see where
timor's new idea is uh coming i i don't
think it's coming this is the position
we currently have on the board which
just invites uh massive simplifications
bishop takes c5 bishop takes e5 rook to
c8 bishop to d4 knight takes c3 and now
it does seem like probably the best
movie in the position is to actually
take on c3 and i think this is what
we're going to see everybody knows that
at this point the players are ready to
sign the scoresheets and move on and
make sure this is what i think we're
going to see it doesn't seem like it is
a very combative
game and uh it does seem like timur came
in today's round wanting to clean
the blood that he had from yesterday's
game against ikaru because he definitely
bled in that one he wanted to regain his
confidence regain his energy and go on
with the clean slate make a quick draw
just go back get arrested
fair fair fair and uh
well once again this is our uh standings
after two rounds of play alejandro i
mean there's been a lot of talk about
rajabov as a candidate right he is the
one that him and digler are the ones
that got here let's say in the most
unusual circumstances whereas everybody
else qualified in one way or another
uh dingley rand got there with this
strange thing
sergei rating of rating while sergey was
banned from the candidates first
completely different violation
completely different subject right but
dinglerang gets in gets the gets a
nomination the other one is rajabov
which is another even stranger
nomination
because qualified a cycle ago which a
cycle ago usually is one year right but
rajabov qualified for this tournament
you could you could say that he
qualified for this tournament in 2019
right right he that's three years ago
that's three years ago when he plays the
world cup i think he wins the world he
wins the world cup in hunting in 2019
right and he does that so long ago right
that are you really wondering it's the
same teamwork and he's been completely
off for two years doesn't really play a
lot of chaz his results have been
you know lackluster
and there's been a lot of talk from
top grad masters including a certain
magnus carlson who they asked you know
does rajava have a chance it says zero
zero zero which is a little exaggerated
but he said zero that's tough uh
our model said one percent
i want i want timor to actually bring
the heat i wanna i want him to show the
haters that hey
i became 27.99 as a teenager right i
beat gary at 15 right i am the great
team with raja wolf i'm going to come
here and win this tournament but you're
not going to do it playing white like
this catalan i wanted to turn our
attention he has nothing to lose
exactly right go for it go for it right
what do you have to lose at this point
exactly exactly i wanted to turn our
attention to the game between fabi
because we have just seen you know a a
vacuum cleaning of the board
and it's a bishop versus knight for rook
four rooks and bishop versus night
ending
normally speaking i'm going to say i
really like white
now you've got to convince me that this
position
is not a big advantage can you do that
for white i think it's a big advantage a
big advantage a big advantage
um i think it's an advantage i just
don't know how big
okay uh let's make some moves shall we
let's uh let's start with c4
so i want you to take
so you would bring my bishop out you'd
be a very i'm nice person
yeah i know i think the only move here
would be seven right king e7 okay so i
will drop my
you attack my rook i dropped my rook uh
back yes and uh i'm going to go ahead
and cheat here because i can see that
there are some correspondence games i
have no idea
really well this is all correspond oh my
god they're actually the position the
position before c4 has been reached 57
times no way quite a few times yeah
157 is what i'm being told so i'm
actually a third of the way there i by
the way have a great great respect for
correspondence players i think that they
play at the highest level of chess so if
157 correspondence players think that
this position with black is
salvageable or good it's not only
correspondence games no no it's not the
last top level games yeah also top level
games actually the engine is just saying
zeros
wow so the computer doesn't give
advantage to any of the size and it does
seem like according to at least the
results in these positions it does seem
like uh draw is probably the most highly
uh anticipated outcome now rook to d2
even rook to d2 was actually played
quite a few times now the idea is that
this rook on d6 is always going to be
targeting next move with the move king
to e7 so you might as well just go ahead
and get it to d2 now this would open the
idea of potentially putting the bishop
on a central position on e4 bishop to d3
followed by uh bishop to e4 as well as
getting ready to double up on the only
open file in the position the d files so
brook to d2 makes a lot of sense this
was played by dominguez versus anand
dominguez versus nepognashi more
recently by one morsin of volodar a
young player from russia big talent from
russia only 14 years of age a grand
master in its own right and he knows a
lot of theory as well it's been played
quite a few times
um and the other way and as well the
correspondence games as well so it does
seem that this one is known one hour and
42 minutes for yashishtav duda so he
definitely is quite aware of what he
needs to do in this position
i think he equalized out of the opening
actually king to e7 followed by rook to
d8 taking advantage of the fact that i
have some nice squares in the center to
put my knight i don't see any problems
for black okay sorry uh
my gosh i mean i i feel like i'm getting
tasered over here so rook to d2 so king
e7 sure let's go king e7 like good
people do
uh bishop to d3 let's go rook d8
very very normal now i was always taught
that uh
in
uh knight versus bishop ending the
the bishop coordinates well
uh with the rooks
that what the bishop really really wants
is majorities
you've got a majority on the king side
or queenside i get a majority elsewhere
so
i've seen vichyanan playing these types
of endings as white and whether he does
the creepy crawly a3 c3 king a2 business
or he just you know
overpowers you know the the the knight
with the bishop by establishing it on
some wonderful albums i always thought
it was good for white these positions
let's go rub six wait which move sorry
rook d6
and
should sure so bishop to e4 how do we
assess the end game after d8 should i
get no a4
you ignore it go rook d8 i guess okay
sorry christian you were saying bishop
e4 yeah my idea was that's why i played
the rook 36 to play rook to d8 and then
i wasn't
sure how to assess this enemy so well if
you do the routine to c1 maybe knight to
b4 is is a question that i have to ask
no no no i don't think so i don't think
so uh
knight to b4
i'm not saying i thought you were
winning or anything without nature
knight to d4 i guess c3 92
well i i haven't i have ideas i can also
go five
i don't know can i go f5 no the knight
was hanging on c6
no no knight d4c after after c3 oh f5
now i apologize i thought that yeah okay
if i can get away with it but i'm not
sure if i can uh this looks like a real
overlapping yeah bishop d3 i forgot
about this movie i thought you had to go
to b1 right but yeah yeah then you got
knight e2 you can trick me around a
little bit
okay well i've
what can i say i live and learn but
again knight to b4 what what do you do
back here yeah i can
i can take everything i mean you want to
see three yeah
that was the intention but even this
okay
[Laughter]
sorry sorry sir knight d5 yeah yeah okay
so you get a position like this but
aren't your queen sight
pawns i think my king is just too active
i think in general you're too active the
knight is fine on d5 it actually has a
lot of jumping squares and i can always
mobilize my majority because i can go
g6f5 and start harassing your bishop and
they're going towards that line by the
way yeah are they i don't feel that
black is worse here k7 bishop d3 is on
the board so you might see that
variation wow we're really rushing
towards
end games today right i mean whether it
be the timor game whether it be the
fobby game right
and uh well yeah
and hikaru
the thing tank
i would be shocked if he doesn't know
this because as i said well he's he's
the big player with this variation as
black he is the player he is the
inspiration of this variation he has
defended this successfully against
everybody that's tried right uh whether
it be la cuangle mamediaro wesley so
no matter who's business that are some
big names
he just defended perfectly every time
that he gets here so
he is on a huge thing
already almost down down by 50 minutes
on the clock
wow he must be remembering his
preparation and it's also very difficult
to try to calculate your way out of this
but if someone can do it that's icarus
exactly well uh the move queen c1
certainly has frozen hikara for a moment
but as we get prepared for our first
break of the day we want to remind
everybody about cubitique alejandro yes
absolutely uh join us here at the
broadcast and we have a special mug for
you guys as well a lot of little
different things with logos at the world
chess hall of fame as well as the
singfield cup and all of them are
available at qboutiquestl.com
support us by going to the website and
get out your checkbook and do some
serious shopping we're going to see you
all on the other side of this brick
we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to our coverage
of round three of the candidates 2022
this is our standings after two games of
chess over there in madrid as we have
fabiana caron and janet
at the top of the leaderboard both of
them won their first round drew against
each other yesterday and a bunch of
people on 50 percent with an asterisk
hikarna cabrera instead of getting two
draws together one one lost the other
exactly very competitive play by hikaru
and we have one uh maurice ashley
grandmaster maurice ashley over in
madrid he's going to join us in about 15
odd minutes
it's always nice if he could keep him
chill on ice for as long as we can
before we get out you know he wants to
explode
um
today
is around a theory i mean we have seen
long long long
including the game of fabiano that i
have on my board right now against duda
and uh it was
the players have got to the position
that we were looking at and i think we
were looking at rook d6 and some
variation like rook d8 and i was sitting
there saying gosh i really like white's
position and the computer's going oh
three zeros and it's like you got
nothing got nothing i'm like
i always thought that these positions
were better for the bishop well we're
gonna see well we're gonna see it but
rook hd one and it seems that duda's
actually a little bit stuck after the
movement hd1 as far as uh
on time i mean he's
answering right away right he's spending
20 minutes on this move uh he perhaps
this is where his notes end or where his
notes become hazy right a lot of the
times we have notes as grandmasters and
we kind of know that there are more
moves in this position we also remember
that perhaps we're not the most
important that you had more than one
option at that point you can probably
choose and start thinking and this is
perhaps that moment because it's
actually played the move g6 it's not the
move that was mentioned by christian but
i see on your database that it's also
been played before uh it makes perfect
sense it makes you you want to use your
majority you stifled the bishop as well
right right
so this has been seen i see on the
database that lanier played this against
vichy all the way back in 2009 wow so
nothing new under the sun in this one
okay and then uh talking about a game
that's just petering out super fast and
that's another of our tournament leaders
where is jan there you are
what to say about this game it was a a
catalan a kind of a dry variation
white's not
doing anything in at this line and we've
got exactly what christians mentioned
a time ago after knight takes c3
if draws were
allowed
to be offered
bishop takes c3 rook takes c3 a4 the
draw would be uh agreed upon no draws
before 40 moves but this one really is
heading
uh
it's going to be a drop
hikaru nakamura let's go back to this
game for a moment because
are we talking about a 30 minute thing a
40 minute thing here i think it's 40 by
this point maybe even more than 40. sure
i can look that up
the move queen c1 seems to have taken uh
hikaru by surprise somebody wake him up
left on his clock and there's no
increment in this tournament
somebody wakey carl up right now it just
reminds me of a funny story that uh
arthur bisguire was playing against uh
bobby fischer
in a u.s open and the night before
bobby had cleaned everybody out in blitz
chess he just took everybody's money but
the problem was that bobby played to
like three o'clock in the morning wiping
wiping the crowd out
and then
arthur made his move looked across the
board and realized that bobby was asleep
he's just
happily sleeping
so arthur says you know i don't want to
win on time
so he made the worst mistake of his life
hey bobby you here well yeah yeah i'm
sorry uh made a move slap the clock and
the game goes into 60 memorable games
oh bobby bodies of brilliancy after
getting woken up
somebody wake up at caro we have been
looking at rook takes d4 have you ever
fallen asleep during a tournament no no
no never although
uh thanks to jet lag there are there
were times when i was just like praying
the game would end a as soon as possible
yeah and it's official now with
the last second 40 sec 40 minute thing
here for hikaru nakamura but just about
a third of his time here uh spent on
only one move it's a crucial move so
it's not like he's allocating time badly
right uh this is a moment where if he
messes up he will lose instantly exactly
so he really needs to be very careful of
what he chooses but
having said that having said all that
this is the way that he could navigate
his way yeah to a balanced position and
it is as you say a very narrow path it's
a very very narrow path very difficult
to calculate over the board if you don't
know it right um
and somehow you're not gonna you're
gonna be shocked this king actually
marches all the way to b5 where the
queen actually happens to
hang out at the moment and we have
looked at this uh line alejandro
um well dare i say it 40 minutes ago
and it was you
who said that you had actually prepped
somebody yes all the way up to something
like here i don't really remember where
we left it off i just remember the idea
that queen b5 was a draw and then i
don't know that person i was preparing
okay you can remember the rest the nice
thing about being a prep somebody that's
a coach yeah i look at all these awesome
lines and i don't have to remember them
yeah yeah
they don't remember i can yell at them
right what are you reading
i was working so hard uh a very very
long convoluted difficult line but at
the end of the day the engines say
it's uh balance and look at this
material imbalance four connected past
pawns uh
the well i mean the pawns are going to
get lost
uh but it would be it would have
appeared that uh a perpetual check
that's very likely is very likely in
this case
uh besides this move
which we think once again is the best
line i was also asking
is hikaru
does he feel like
he should play
for
did i say it three results e7 e5 i think
that if he wanted to do that yeah i
should have done it earlier like not
earlier in moose but make them move
faster uh-huh it goes faster if you
really want to go through
this game and make it as sharp as
possible and you want to fight
head-to-head right somewhere in this
lines yeah then you probably want to
play this with still time on the clock
with no question about it uh
as these very very complex uh variations
come down
towards the time control
having that extra 10 minutes and it took
off
takes d4
christian he did it he did it he did it
i mean look this is what i think his uh
train of thought was i know that rook
takes d4 is probably going to lead to
that very forced variation i also know
that there is no way in which i can give
a perpetual at the end and i know that
furuja probably has something in store
for me there do i go there
and wait for what furuja has in store
for me or do i go with the move e5
probably first i would have been
prepared for the move e5 as well he
tried to understand the nuances of the
position he tried to understand whether
e5 offers him a direct path to a clear
position clear assessment of the
position he didn't get there and right
now he chose to uh go with this move
rook to d4 i have to say 40 minutes for
one move when you're playing a long game
without any increment that's going to
cost him towards the end of the game but
let's take a look at uh one game that we
haven't been uh keeping our eyes on and
that is the one between dingley wren and
richard for the grunfeld variation we
left it off after this move bishop to b5
rook to c8 queen to d2 c takes d4 c
takes d4 and actually i was looking at
the top games here and there's actually
only three games uh being played and the
top one is giri anish versus dingley ren
so ding actually played it with the
black pieces now that's quite an
interesting strategy so you were
surprised most likely by richie reports
choice of the grunfeld and now you're
taking cues from a previous game that
you played with the black pieces and
perhaps felt uncomfortable with this is
what i'm seeing from dingley ran right
now and actually let's take a look at
that game queen to d2 e6 was the move
essay in that game and this was the move
played in all the other games in the
database but
instead of that
and by the way i do think that uh this
movie e6 and uh the next sequence of
moves offered white a slight advantage
because white managed to create a pass
pawn with the move d5 in this position
and i do think that black had quite uh
some difficulties defending this one and
equalizing this position let's see what
happened in the actual game that we have
today on our hands queen to d6 and it
came fast from richie rapport this is
the novelty that he prepared from home
queen to d6 rook to d1 and now he uh
spent quite a sizable amount of his time
15 minutes on this move
queen to b for offering the queen trade
we know that in general in greenfield
situations if uh black manages to
exchange uh the queens is going to be
quite comfortable especially in this
situation where after queen takes before
knight x before you attack
instantaneously two points the pawn on
e4 and the pawn on a2 it does seem like
this gives black enough dynamics uh to
maybe even get a better position now
queen uh trade was rejected by dingley
ran queen to d3 finally we have the move
e6 on the board and now we have this
position at some point white is going to
have to focus on the expansion in the
center with the move d5 or on the side
with the move h4 now that the queen is a
little bit off
i can go h4 and i can try to create some
problems that way what is the queen
doing on b4 right now i i understand
my queen is tight defense of the bishop
b5 but i don't see any other jobs for
the queen on b4 for the moment you do
put some pressure on the pawn on d4 and
you're probably going to try to increase
that pressure with the move rook to d8
and this is going to be the battle i'm
going to try to open you up and soften
you on the king side and you're going to
try to increase the pressure in the
center at some point provoke me to play
the move d5 which might become a
liability in the long term let's see how
the players are going to assess this
position how they're going to continue
the position one hour and 15 minutes 16
minutes for dingley ran one hour and 19
minutes for richie rapport quite close
this matchup is and there's a lot of
content coming your way in this game
because the position remains extremely
complex yeah
for me that that position of the
grunfeld that that christian has been
talking about that's like a really a
classic grunfeld position black has the
majority of like
the two versus one uh white has more
play in the center as i
find there it is
uh with his uh majority in the center
oftentimes
he wants to be he wants to play d4 d5 uh
and get a passer as quickly as possible
in this case uh provoking knight e5
wouldn't be that good
um
christian you're a grundfeld player uh
you like these positions as black you
feel comfortable in them
um
but
is it even
give it a like i like it yeah yeah
no i i like the position i i don't have
any immediate weaknesses i didn't get
the bulldozed out of the opening and
which sometimes happens in yeah kings
indian and the defenses and everything
else well the grim third is is a special
opening because you know that probably
you're going to be equalized with very
good play it's a very good opening if
you know it but one way in which um
players as white prepare against the
grunfeld they don't have a stable
repertoire they don't play only one line
they try to always diversify and that
leads to the player with the black piece
is usually getting surprised that's why
we have general specialists yeah like
mvl that is essays the green flag we
don't have any other players at the
elite level that are doing that because
if they do that they generally get
surprised quite often and this is what
mvl is also uh
has said quite a few times but he trusts
his memory he trusts his preparation he
got caught a few times and uh lost a lot
of important games so
that's the trade-off by playing the
ghouls it feels to me that magnus of
amazing things that magnus has done
magnus has
certainly at one norway tournament it
seemed like he was slaying the gruntfelt
pretty yes
you know like
leaving no no doubts
quite a few times he played it with
black also didn't he play it against uh
vishanan
in in their match in their first match
yes yes yes exactly you did yeah
as we were saying it felt like the groom
fell
fashion wise has fallen off a little bit
true true i mean
again uh victor korchnoy gary kasparov
some of the really really leading
leading players all played the group of
help now you know again there's an mdl
you feel like a sitting duck when you
play the game and i think that's the
issue right the issue is that you're
just kind of waiting for white to show
your hands
respond yeah
h4 by the way the softening up
i'm telling you today's round uh the
players are just
deep in there deep in theory yeah this
is still the game that uh christian was
mentioning gearing against different
game
yeah this is uh geary versus nepal oh
sorry sorry you're my show game so the
one that i was mentioning was giri
versus ding this is actually geary
versus and it does feel like giri is
some sort of a specialist in this
variation
all right everything wow so uh this game
very very rich game again this ending
fabi versus uh
aduda it's one of those
i always thought that these were good
for white but boy also no novelties yet
no
i don't know who this is some 2370
player
lost to la croix liam
in 2011
with with well la cuang was black okay
and well that is a really big rating
difference so yeah that doesn't really
speak too much to the position
but oh my
okay knight a5 a very different approach
by duda we were actually anticipating
that black may at some point want to
trade all the rooks
with rook d6 and look d8 knight a5
and also i find it intriguing let's just
use that word for a moment that he
didn't follow it up with the move f7 f5
um i would have thought that you you say
you're gonna go and you're gonna say
guys before we get into this end game
what is happening with hikaru because
they got to this position and right now
alejandro you said that queen to d7 is
the only move
that's what i remember of course
he already might be wrong six minutes on
it and he hasn't played it well what is
happening with hikaru does he really not
remember this first line if it doesn't
i'm afraid he's in deep trouble right
now right what what are our alternatives
to queen d7 because there are other
videos right i mean if you go to b7 that
doesn't really matter a lot of stuff
and i go to d2 right so this is the idea
of queen to d7 to cut the king from
going to d2 and i forgot i forgot i was
actually wondering about this why cannot
why can't you start with queen c2 no
sorry
knight with knight c2 probably king d1
and then you go
it seems like this is a line as well
queen to a4 you can take on e4 and next
but then you have to defend this end
game and maybe this is
what he wants brooke and bishop
yeah this one actually looks good for
white yeah that would actually looks
very good for one all right that clears
the cowboys and then it is the queen d7
i don't see another move right i mean we
can explain to the audience in these
last 38 minutes yes well
i mean obviously
let christian take this one why is king
g7 bad in this position the angel will
show you very quickly king g7
bishop h6 seems to be the right move not
e5 now the question is
because of knight to d5 right queen to
g3 and then queen to b7 and there's
another scene
the best you have is a perpetual at this
wow bishop to e7 and then just perpetual
queen h3 queen to g3 not allow the king
to go to f8 but what you can do is
actually go bishop to h6
king to h7 if you go here you get
checkmated after queen to g5 if you go
to h8 queen to h4 and the king on h8 is
just much worse place than the king on
h7 so king to h7
by elimination becomes the best movie in
the position and does feel like this one
just gives white a tremendous advantage
uh bishop to g5 is a big threat you have
to defend that and the only way to
defend that is with this explosive move
knight to f5 but unfortunately for you
this just leaves
white with a tremendous position
wow a good favorable question go back to
that moment christian before knight f5
yes because now i'm trying to trying to
that's what i was wondering
so you can give me a check
you can give me another check you can
take my rook but now you get checkmated
yeah yeah yeah that's the distraction
yeah so king g7
bad move bad move king g7 queen d7
uh what we would like
we would say already a 10 minute thing
for hikaru box yeah i don't remember
forced this position that well it's not
a line i play but i i thought queen
december i mean when when the engine
said queen i was like yeah i have seen
this variation by force
he's not remembering and that is very
worrisome at the moment because he has
35 minutes left now he's still okay he's
still fine theoretically he just needs
to make a move right uh again the clock
times a big difference
oh yeah biggest difference biggest
difference in the tournament
ever of all of them one hour and 15
minutes one hour and 51 minutes to 43 35
minutes wow
difference
wow
okay that's that's not a good sign
that's not a good sign especially in a
position that's so sharp and so
demanding
wow okay um
remarkable i i'm i i'm just
amazed that
the players
uh play these lines and then it often
comes down to something that's so
incredibly sharp where you have one move
and one move only
and this is actually the way that this
nimzon indian works out it's a very move
by moved indian once you get the bishop
to g5 and you start maneuvering around
with the queen because black tries to
force the c5 move by force
and
it leads to this kind of crazy tactical
complications does c5 work or does c5
not work right and it might not work
because you have e45 because you might
be forced to play g5 and kick out the
bishop and then white says well i can't
allow you to get everything you want let
me give up a knight right and then
you've got to do this takes g5 yeah
everything is double edged right yeah
okay wow uh okay so once again everybody
if you're joining us late shame on you
queen d7 bishop takes f6 knight c2 check
gets into one of the most crazy material
imbalances you're
ever likely to see so right here at
first blush you see this bishop on f6
and you think to yourself i'm getting
made it
but the problem is the desirable queen
h6 actually just meets with an immediate
queen trade queen takes and for example
king c1 you go queen to check
and it's game over
so i have to do everything
very forcing
and i can pick up the f7 pawn with the
check i can pick up the e6 pawn with a
check and the knight
and at the end of the day i have four
connected pass bonds in the bishop
against a rook except it's black's turn
and black will play queen takes f2
probably queen takes g2 and white will
end up making a perpetual check right
the date or rook effect at the end also
works and this is a crazy complication
it's also very difficult to assess this
position from the beginning right it's
not just do you get here you could get
here and still come to the incredibly
wrong conclusion who is better here you
could assume that white is better in
this position right it's not true
because i have analyzed this before but
otherwise you could if you ask me give a
knee-jerk reaction who's better i'd be
like i don't know i actually have to
think there's no way i could assess this
in a few minutes right and seeing this
position all the way back
from the position on queen f4 and
assessing it wow that's that's hard
that's where i think it's really
impressive what these players do they
calculate these very very deep lines but
also they have remarkable judgment they
go oh this line is an advantage for me
but it's not as much as an advantage
that i have currently on the board so
i'm not going to play it if i play this
forcing line i'll reduce my advantage
i'm going to play a different line their
judgment
you know it's just extraordinary
well we'll keep an eye on this game uh
has
timor and jan discovered a way of uh a
repetition very unprofessional very
unprofessional uh rook d7 a6 rook g6
um
okay that's enough of looking at this
game that was the end of that and we
expect something of the nature of like
e3 and one day you're just going to go
rook to c7 you're going to give up this
pawn you're going to force a passive
brook then the rook is going to go over
here
and then the rook is going to go over
here and you're going to pick up the
pawn and it's going to be four versus
four and the players will at last make a
draw can we just go kg7
that's that's deep uh once again let me
let me turn to the game of fobby just
for a moment because we're in this
ending that you've mentioned that
uh liam won
with the black pieces right yeah um
i'm looking at this knight on a5 and i'm
going well why is the knight on a5 and
the correct answer is i guess it's going
to c4 yasser
that seems like it is going to c4 but
really really shiny in my grandmaster
okay
uh i invite you all right i invite you
king to c2
so how do we find out before on a good
day i just want to play a4 and open up
the a file
knight c4 now i don't want to give up my
bishop
that ending i think is
zeros all across the board but rookie
two
hits my pawn yep
indirectly you have to think on c4 first
but that's okay
yeah
maybe it's not the most comfortable way
to do that uh because i want to play the
move king f6 here yes i would prefer to
play the move king f6 with my pawn
already on f5
so perhaps i don't play the move knight
c4 i start with f5 aha uh-huh and by the
way i just had this this like
thing that rushed through my mind when
you played the move king f6 i was
thinking about bishop take c4
i want you to play rook takes d1 okay
very nice i'm not really sure why you're
doing this that's giving us exchange
yeah exactly i was trying to get three
connected passers you think this is so
good for a white huh
uh it might be actually it might be if
you don't
win you know you win a pawn somehow
uh
with rook a1 i wanted to play bishop
takes a6 but it did flash across my mind
it's an interesting line it would
definitely change the character of the
position we're not going to see any of
this because uh fabia actually starts
with the move rookie too actually
so we might see this if you go rookie
two king f16 c2 knight c4 but this is
maybe a more precise move order may
bobby yeah it does hit the pawn
immediately which that allows you to
play f5 and king next exactly so now
uh there's a pertinent question on the
position right how do you defend the
spot on e5 i am taking it directly
uh again king f6 it's okay but it's not
the move you want to play before the
move f5 yeah you kind of step in front
of your pawn right and then after king
c2
we make some pretense
yeah i mean i do have ideas as white
maybe the move rook to e1 is
disconcerting maybe a4 yeah i don't know
there's a move that you don't want to
face i don't know good day maybe the
move b3 will start actually corralling
this night not in the sense that i'm
going to win it's scary but you reduce
its activity yeah and you start
eventually seeing why a bishop is more
powerful than a knight on open boards
yeah that's that's what it's all about
and again uh even though the game is
gone slowly
hikaru did not play queen d7 he played
knight c2 check
immediately i guess i think we've seen
this i guess we're going yeah christian
showed us this yeah i guess you were
going into that end game
and that ending was queen d7 check i
don't like that end game right king
takes c2 queen a4 an a4 check now don't
ask me if you can't make another move
but this was the ending that we had well
you can't i can answer that one right if
you move to the c file there's queen c4
uh sorry queen no i was going to go b3
that i don't know
i guess you still have to go queen take
c4 yeah and i just thought well why not
yeah why not play b3 we get the same
ending and guess what it's another one
of those rook and bishop versus rook and
knight endings and again
i want to emphasize this majorities on
both sides i
thought favors the bishops and finally
hikaru is playing right into this line
but this this idiom is very unpleasant
that was my feeling as well yeah i would
much rather play uh white's position
here
uh
even not just because i have a a passer
already h2h4
but in general um
the
activity of the pieces i think is going
to favor white now it's still not
uh wham bam
and over overtime king to b1 was played
actually not b3 and was played quite
quickly once again this is all a part of
showing his preparation
right i don't i don't know why
why is king b1 better than b3
i guess you don't want to give the c3
square for the knight
so you think now the question is why not
uh why not on c1 because of queen c4 no
that that's clear c4 uh that was so he
played king b1 and we're just having a
uh
a question
why didn't we play b3
and i'm assuming by the way
i'm assuming there's no choice
other than queen takes e4 is there no no
you know just diet right it feels like
i'm going to die if i don't do it
yeah no it's forced it must be forced
i don't see another alternative
yeah
uh are you trying to go knight c3 and
yeah perpetual that's exactly right but
you're not giving the perpetual so
rookie one
i am not no i don't think so
i control the d8 square
so i'm gonna go to the d file
you're absolutely right christian you
are controlling this and then i don't
question the very desirable look d8
sorry trinity
nice okay so that does mean i have to
play queen e4 and they're just right
into it yeah they're going into the end
game or as you said or you die queen e4
queen e4 knight e4 and we get this
ending i'm expecting
uh bishop e3
um okay which before immediately played
reza is still in his preparation that's
what i wanted to say i wanted to ask you
both
christian
it seems to me
that ali raza is still in his
preparation he for sure is but i told
you guys how deep
down this rabbit hole did he go probably
more than more than we think i i think
you've finished no no he he did not
finish at this point i can guarantee you
that he did not finish at this point
really he knows the plans at least the
plans the next few moves and
the plans that connect with those moves
and
to be honest
the more i look at this end game i think
hikaru is in is in some dangers no this
is a very dangerous end game and unlike
some of the positions that we saw which
were more forcing
in this particular engine white has all
the trumps and i i am checking out with
a strong engines on the evaluation it's
right it's very close to zero but
i i have the feeling that it's a very
close to zero that an engine can play
easily right whereas for us it's it's
very i'll
gain between two human beings it's very
impractical to play this for the white
for the black side uh whereas white
splines are very simple you play f3 you
destabilize your knight two push it away
c2 eventually try to win a pawn on the
queen side because they're all in dark
squares they try to get advantage of
rook on d1
you can imagine that sometimes if we do
trade the rooks that the end game is
just actually hopelessly lost right now
from
black's point of view black is thinking
that he would like his knight anchored
so one of the most attractive squares i
think in the position is d5 but i also
think d3 is an attractive
uh square if i could play the move c4
and if i could play c4 and
you know somehow uh put my knight on
let's call it the ideal square for the
moment
uh then i'm feeling i'm fighting well
yeah i agree uh after bishop f4 already
played by the way um knight f6 is
already played also knight f6 yeah he's
going with your idea you like the anchor
square and it's going to d5 exactly
and it's always been one of those
peculiar things that i discovered as i
got better at chess
knights actually love protection and the
better they're protected
the happier knight is so think of a
knight on d5 right pawn on c4 and a
bishop on g2
okay it loves the this knight is like in
its zenith right he loves this type of
protection and you want your knights to
be protected whereas bishops are
long-range pieces you can stick them on
a1 and they'll be
really effective we have a first result
in this round number three teamwork
rajabov has drawn against
no surprise there nothing being
presented to the candidates uh today by
teamwork i mean nepal more than happy to
make a draw with the black pieces right
and it was just a nothing game it really
wasn't the first one in the tournament i
think
one of these kinds of games where i
think uh christian said it very well uh
he lost he lost a a nasty game yesterday
against hicaro
did
timor and in the old soviet school of
chasses you know you immediately stopped
the bleeding with the draw but he really
kind of wasted a white today i i feel
and
kind of you kind of wonder how many
chances you do get right right it's so
hard to win against anybody in this
tournament but you have to present some
idea that's a and a challenge as well
also this is operating under the
assumption that he actually wants to win
this event
and this might be harsh
against timor but does he really believe
or want to win this event
i don't know
i would hope
i hope that he's there to win it i will
convince i mean i i like the 2 million
euro prize fund in a world championship
match i've always said for the good of
chess i should be a millionaire
for the good of chess i mean if it's for
the good of chess i think so too exactly
uh
a nothing game fine
well uh let's take a look
we'll leave that game because nothing
happened right we have a tweet and
remember join the conversation with us
on twitter on uh youtube live on twitch
we are checking all of those we're also
even checking reddit for your questions
take a look at the tweet that we have
for you today
and it is
and here it is from freedom master talia
cervantes is actually my student hello
uh which player not in the candidates
right now would you like to see playing
in this tournament lavon levon is a very
man that is a it's hard to beat level
yeah yeah i mean i think wesley lavonne
are two choices i i would really like
um
see normally i would have said mvl and
mvl that was the other thing
nvl is really high up there for me he
just had such a
he's got a bad year he's recovered a bit
right yeah he's recovered a bit but
besides his amazing uh world blitz
championship was she won yeah in
classical chess specifically he's he's
fallen a little bit he hasn't had the
results that you're used to he's not the
2800 that he was once
um
but still when you think about
candidates
you have to put mbl on the list right
right exactly um i thought it was really
funny uh i don't know why uh today in in
particular tickled my funny bone but as
you were uh starting the show you're
saying you know like we've got classical
chess
120 minutes for the first you know 40
moves and uh
double round robin
1948 the world championship was a quad
quadruple
eight player quadruple round robin
eight player quadruple round robin with
a germans oh yeah that was long
though you modern players you have it
easy today i wanted to turn our
attention to ding
laren and richard report because as
as my friend
bomber bill mcgeary said position blowed
up
bomber
bill mcgeary all right out of seattle
the position blowed up on us look what
just happened definitely did uh we left
it at this
moment we had just seen the softening
move h4
as ding uh looks to press on the king
side with the move h5 so richard said
look you know in the grunfeld it's all
about putting pressure on the center
christian will tell you that and then
after the move bishop g5 the novelty
king
was the first novelty knight rook to d8
was a bad move what rook to d8 a very
natural rook to d8 was a bad move really
it was played before
by jan nepomnyashi and answered
incorrectly by anish giri with this move
a3 which allowed queen to e7 and after
bishop to g5 you get
the extra option of covering this
diagonal with bishop to f6 which
actually allows black to get back into
the game but after bishop to g5 which is
a novelty indeed but a novelty that just
shatters black's position because right
now it forces
black to
sacrifice an exchange you don't want to
play f6 absolutely not don't play f6
there's one
benjamin feingold that actually never
play f6 he's definitely thrown in this
case now what else rook to d7 put the
rook on this diagonal controlled by the
bishop absolutely not you want to go
back to f8 absolutely not because for
example if you go to a f8 i just simply
start kicking off your queen a3 e5 queen
to h3 go back behind the each point i'm
going to get h5 next move you lost too
many tempes also d5 is a huge threat
everything blows up for uh black right
now so you have to sacrifice you're
forced to sacrifice at this point knight
takes d4 bishop takes d8 rook takes d8
this is the position we currently have
on the board but where is the
compensation
i'm i'm trying to see it i understand
you do have a beautiful bishop
unopposed
by a white's dark square bishop
but
you're an exchange down and i don't have
any immediate weaknesses you don't have
any dynamic play against my king which
you usually get in exchange for uh a
sacrifice and you don't actually
actually it's just it's the opposite
right it feels like black's king is
sweet exactly exactly so foreign
let's go down the rabbit hole yeah let's
go down the line that looses
e2 knight takes e2 okay
rook takes d1 sure and then he wants to
take on e4 and i want to take on e4 with
the queen with the queen or with with a
queen yeah that doesn't matter too much
so i apparently i can just go bishop
everybody yeah you think don't i have
two points a week
one
but
i'll have two
i'm sorry petersfield lives for this
ending i understand
it's really bad you lose one of the
points oh i i think you're going peter
right now he'll be like no
you lose one of the pawns the idea being
that if you go king to g7 you put the
king
on the seventh rank which allows me to
create a double attack that is the
problem if you go rook 28 and i get
first of all right right now but if you
attack it like this if you allow me to
go a5 bishop to c5 defend like that it's
a draw we know that we understand that
but rook to d7 just wins the pawn
because you cannot protect the a7 i mean
you might just say you're in trouble you
might make a draw but you'll suffer
forever you're low or very good i'll put
my king on g8 for just a second so i
have two pawns for the xj you have one
you're losing one you're you're losing
one you're losing one yeah well at this
moment i didn't realize when i was going
into this line i'm going to lose one by
force but i'm just looking at this and i
i can't pick off this h-pawn
like there's no line here i don't think
so no well first of all you have to get
off the pin so the only way to get off
the pin is with king g7 and then v7 is
coming yep
so
wow what do you do
okay i've uh and then you're just hoping
you're not dead lost right you're hoping
that somehow you can create and if i
don't trade queens uh christian if i
take with the bishop on e4 then that's
an option as well but once again you're
going to stop sephoria and actually i
can force the queen trade that's the
same position
exactly into the same position
uh
would you believe
don't trade queens in that last moment
sorry bishop f a rook d a king g7 no no
i go here first what what what
i got bishop f a yeah no no but then i
take rook d4
that's that's lost right d4 oh nasty it
is what it is don't go into that wow
wow
and ding needs this game he really he
really does he really really does and we
already have one result so there you see
janna forming she is currently at the
top of the leaderboard that's because he
has an extra game he drew against timor
rodrigo same thing with teamwork he has
an extra game uh we're still waiting on
every other result this was a nothing
game but for dingler and this is huge
he's the only player right now with half
a point yep that's not good not good and
he is playing his second wine of the
tournament and as the highest rated
player you want to win one of them no
question about it he's lucky about going
backwards there he actually played the
move h
five instead of what we were looking at
i think it was
okay so how did we get here
wait what did what just happened
like my mind blipped
my mind blipped oh bishop a6 is what we
were looking at right right bishop ace
he did none of that he actually played
them with h5
right away
which is kind of a funny looking move
because everything is hanging and you
can kind of forcefully play bishop a6
and instead you take the time to play
the move h5 now the interesting thing
about the movie h5 yeah is that in those
variations where i do give a check
on d8 and you have to cover with the
bishop if i get my pawn to h6 you might
never move again no that is like the
worst that's the worst feeling you feel
like completely helpless in an eternal
eternal pin right oh that's a terrible
um
is
i i is my spidey sense completely
failing me i mean i take this pawn only
to prevent you from getting what you
just described as my worst nightmare the
eternal pin on the on the back rank yeah
but now now now you take on d4 and i
think you lose by force uh oh
that hurts you're busted yeah
f8
and i i mean because there's no way
right this holds ah well rook takes the
one and that's quite important because
the bishop b5 is not hanging yeah so
it's not hanging at all queen g3 is very
important tying up the bishop on this g7
and after rook d1 d1 queen takes b5 yeah
you just cannot do that because of rook
d8 checkmate
28 or kc8
that's a kind of a funny background made
i mean i've seen so many back ranked
checkmating patterns but this one where
you're not allowed to play bishop f8
unusual unusual
all right well
uh
a very exciting game here by dingler and
we've already explained why it's so
important for the chinese player to get
off the schnite if you will and get a
victory as he's currently one and a half
points behind the tournament leader nepo
stay tuned we'll see you on the other
side of this break and see if ding rain
can break through
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here live
coverage of round three of the
candidates 2022 this are the standings
with one game already finished is this
match between jan and pognashi and timur
rajabov in which absolutely nothing
happened draw drop that's all we need to
say about that game and we have three
remaining ones all of them are still in
a fight uh to summarize and going around
the horn yeah alireza is nursing a very
small but permanent advantage against
hikaru nakamura we're still gonna have
to see a long end game there
for the young frenchman to try to
overcome hikaru in his favorite opening
with black exactly it's one of these
you've got a majority on the queen side
that is hikaru does but white has a
majority going on over here on the king
side
alireza's last move f2 f3 is a clear
indication of what he's got on his
agenda he just wants to go g4 h5 and
push him baby get those pawns running it
is a good plan uh how do we stop it
yes except for one small issue
the fact that
white pardon me black's king is so close
to those past problems right if you put
your pawn on g5 that would be
egregiously bad right i would go king g6
and i would blockade the pawn yeah you
always want to advance them on the
opposite color of your bishop exactly
exactly but if you uh
if you get your pawn to h5 and then you
you don't get to play g5 so easily like
the knight might swing back over to f6
for example you might get stuck yeah so
uh nursing this majority to a
two pass pawn majority on king sides
going to be rather awkward if
at all possible and i really hate i
really like this move rocket shade it
targets the h4 pawn in a way that it
doesn't let it move and it also doesn't
let more importantly the g-pawn move
precisely and not only that i think it
actually has a threat uh i think f4 is a
threat so let's go rook hwan right i
think you have to right i will see okay
rook h1
no the rook g1 rook h3
rook h3 that's not exactly what you
wanted to do in terms of uh maybe uh
it's awkward
i'm not sure i'm not sure but i can just
sit so let's go king c2 let's try my
part is to push them all right
eventually you're going to have to go h5
push it i push it all right let's go h5
okay that's what i'm saying eventually
you're going to have to go h5 sure now
let me ignore you let's go b5
that's okay continue pushing i
understand you wanted to go e4 i wanted
to go knight f6 and e4 ah knight of six
and e4 i actually really like that like
maybe back here i wanted to just go
through b5 because okay sure i want to
see white's plan if i am naive if i am
naive and i don't do anything
i want to see exactly push how you're
going to make baking progress push them
h6 h6 all right
okay g6 i thought cake g6 okay
h7 push it here you have
some tricks
swinging rook d6
ah i'm starting to feel it
i i don't know if i should but i'm
starting to kristen's got the good
feeling got a good vibe going i don't
know why i like this i still don't know
why okay
i mean he is tricking me and he's
convincing me if the truth of of what
what he's saying but let me take my
approach i just wanted to play knight f6
and e4 that way i absolutely ensure
that you will never get too connected
past pawns on the green side king side
easy for me to say so knight f6 uh okay
okay all right
so what if i continue pushing
h5 h5
man's on a mission he sure is i still
don't really understand i go e4 again g4
so if you if i take
you the knight you have to go back
i mean it's a certain moment i just got
to stop this guy right yeah but it's
pretty stopped right it's gonna be stuck
on h6 and if that's okay it's not like
permanently defended on h6 i can always
go knight g5 and pick it up that's all
right so i'm gonna go a4 now
and then i think we get a draw right
away yeah right away right a6 b5 no no
no no no we don't get the draw
you don't get a truck
what is your plan here uh man is being
uh tough
i don't get it ac yeah a6 go a6 you want
knight f6 or do you want i want to push
i want to be able to play king g6 and
i'm perfectly comfortable
a6 so how do you do it yes i wanted to
play knight f6
and i wanted to force you to play h6
and then i thought okay if my king's on
g6 you're never gonna go king d3 right
that's why i played a4 i want to go to
c4
you want to go to c4 and then try to go
a6 and create something okay
let's see you go ahead go to c4 by the
way none of this is going to happen
because he actually played bishop g5 i
feel like it's better here
uh not i i thought i did a good job at
corralling the h-pawn
but
sorry to interrupt our wonderful
analysis uh top level stuff there
christian but he actually played bishop
to g5 after f3 rook h8 bishop to g5 and
i like this move yeah it's all very
because it keeps
the whole concept of it alive
i like i like this more than putting my
rook on h3 yeah i just felt oh boy what
what what was our rook doing there right
yeah
uh more challenging for hikaru is bishop
g5 and it's on the board it does feel
like black only has one move in this
position i'm afraid that white gets in
the move rookie one
and then
you don't have like an
it's not like why it's winning what do
you mean by that it's like it's not
white's winning but if i get in rookie
one and you don't get an e5
i feel like i'm going to have a lot of
time to
rearrange my pieces right whereas i
think black really wants to get those
pawns rolling all the time so let's go
e5 that's why i'm saying that i think
the e5 would be the only move i consider
in this position okay and then i'm
assuming g4 as well right and now comes
the question do you go f4 or do you go
king e6 and try to keep the pen well f4
is my dream
whites
i think it's a treat
because finally i've got two connected
past bombs and somehow your bishop is
not getting trapped well i've got uh
i've got an escape valve i do have the
e3 square though yeah
let's go right here right 93
okay let's say i want to come over
and down
[Music]
yeah you
can go g8 on e4 right
to g8
pause by the way of course
position is very concrete right yeah it
is it is very concrete yes i'm actually
teasing whether or not i can play bishop
h6 and g5 but you will play night and
and by the way guys yes he
didn't think that e5 is by any way uh
forced and he played the move c4 whoa
really wow okay so rook h a bishop
excuse me bishop to g5 c4
a move actually that we were attracted
to
yeah and some other positions right
right
right and
okay
this
this is going to be just a great game i
mean you've got your trumps your
majority on the
king side black has a good knight on d5
and he's trying to
get him
or is this a game turning into a three
uh result game no
i still would favor white i would say
it's closer to a two result game than a
three result game yeah i mean of course
in any game of chess anything can happen
but right it'll be hard to imagine that
with proper play
black ever really gets winning chances
at all exactly i mean
okay but uh definitely something to keep
our eye on uh i wanted to go uh to our
other tournament
leader going into the round and that was
it's funny because it's a similar end
game right right yeah
uh it's rook and bishop versus russia
versus
yeah you know i it was some
tournament it might have been a sinkhole
cup where it was like everybody was
playing bishops with papa's colors
for like one entire round it was like
crazy what's going on and now we're
playing rook and bishop versus a rook
bishop d okay the knight strangely
enough we thought it was heading to c4
guess not
we were wrong they were very wrong it's
heading to c5 and
here we go
this is not as easy as the other
variation the other game in which i was
thinking why it has to be the one for
choice this one is not so clear to me
because black is more active than in the
other game the king of a1 makes a worse
impression here than it actually does on
the other game right uh whereas the king
on f6 is rather well placed and my
majority which in the other one i'm
almost immediately advancing
here my majority is very stuck
meaning it's not so easy for you to get
in a4 slash c4 or b4 yeah and you can
look at you can look at the break c4 and
then you realize it's not a full break
because once you get b4 in as black you
yeah you get a passport congratulations
but your bishop on f1 is so bad yeah
this is one of those things that
the bishop starts
uh querying you and saying coach
why did you
cut my diagonal here uh i think uh you
you got to do
you you've got to be a little bit more
sophisticated
when your approach is white you can't
just be
too forcing bring your king up
maybe on a good day your king actually
belongs on e3 before you start
finagling on the on the queen's like
he's not void of ideas right even even a
move like g5 takes takes king air force
considerable not saying it's necessarily
good but right you start even looking at
variations like that
and uh
you know you are getting some pretty
nice activity over here that king
on f4 the pawn on h4 the pawn on f this
feels like this feels uh christian like
a far more three-way three result game
right this yeah this feels like a very
whole game to me yeah yeah no i i agree
with you guys
very interesting very intriguing end
games we have on our hands but let's not
forget we still have this game between
uh dingley wren and richie rapport which
is uh
well
developing quite nicely because h5
bishop to e5 was played right to get rid
of any sort of background checkmate
ideas for uh white also potentially uh
including some bank rack uh back rank
checkmate ideas for blackjack because
before we go too much into this detail
yasser and i were wondering we thought
bishop f6 was a more natural move than
bishop which was basically the same
according to the engine as well yes
oh okay well there you go
you guys are good
we know
um yeah the bishop e5 was a little uh
perplexing but please continue but i
like the idea right okay so this queen
on b4 nicely placed up to this point but
at some point i'm gonna have to give it
another job and the way i see it with
this move bishop to e5
a regular idea after you white uh played
h4 h5 is to actually go behind the pawn
on h4 so i see this queen to e7 queen to
h4 as a potential idea in the future
now what is white going to do next
bishop to a6 hasn't been played yet i
was looking at a3 of course you still
cannot take on b5 because queen takes b5
and the rook is hanging on d8 right but
now after a3 then we go queen to e7 and
now the position develops in a different
way because i'm starting to have my own
threats queen to h4 if i force you to
take on g6 i think this exchange is
going to favor black because that's
going to open up the h violin and the
only player that i can see taking
advantage of that against the opposing
king is black either with rook to h8
coming either with queen to h4 coming so
i like this move bishop to e5 i
understand bishop to f6 maybe it feels a
little bit more natural for you guys
this move bishop to e5 for me it looks a
bit more dynamic and i like to see that
from richie rapport of course
white after bishop e5 still has the move
bishop to a6 which leads to more or less
very similar end games to the ones that
we were discussing unless you want to go
bishop to a8 and play that position so
if you go knight take c2 queen take c2
rook takes d1 rook takes d1 and now you
take on e4 now it's an improved version
because after rook to d8 you have the
extra king to g7 you don't have to get
on that unpleasant pin with bishop to f8
absolutely but with the bishop on e5 you
have to contend with these two bishops
being on the same file so now i can try
to take advantage of that with the move
rook to e1 creating more weaknesses in
your position you're forced to play the
move f5 right you cannot move any of the
bishops because you're going to lose the
other one i cannot play them well i can
but it's not going to lead to anything
f3 is going to be met with bishop to d4
and actually i'm not even sure who is
going to be better in this position
to d5
now bishop c4 bishop to ex you need to
get bishop c4 in right and this is the
move after f5 you go bishop to c4 king
to f7 king to f1 and you still
start attacking the position as it is
and taking advantage of the fact that
there's three pieces that you can target
on the e file
and you have the only rook on the board
so f3 already wins a pawn right
this is the position that the players
are right now looking at and i do think
this type of end game would favor ding
is he's the only player that can play
for an advantage
perhaps richie rapport if ding manages
to find this move bishop to a6 is going
to look at his end games
try to analyze them and come to the
conclusion that he doesn't want to
suffer
and
perhaps he's going to choose something
like bishop to aaa try to keep more
pieces on the board keep the dynamic
play on the board and uh take his
chances like that let's see what's going
to happen christian this this is one of
those positions i think that i find
black i want to keep the queens on the
board so if you don't mind looking at
that line with 92 queenie two rook d one
rook d one bishop e4 how how how are
those apples
bishop takes e4 yeah not queen takes it
um
this is actually completely losing
because of bishop d3
oh i take on e5 yeah so you take take
and now h6 you have to contend with that
effectively the bishop on f6 uh yeah the
the bishop on e5 is loose
absolutely right you don't even have g
takes h5 rook takes e3 is not a
possibility but i have this move queen
to f6
threatening queen to d8 and there's no
way to uh stop that okay if you do
bishop c2 rook to d8 is going to come
that's going to win the queen in one
move so this looks hurtful
it looks terrible
he's not going to go for that we we know
that but first of all
white has to find this move bishop to a6
i'm not sure
how easy it is for white to play that
move and uh how tempted he will be to
try to
dislodge this queen from b4 and play the
move a3 which i think is the more
natural approach well bishop a6
has a lot of things going for it i must
say it does yeah i i i would be
attracted as white to the move
h5h6 i mean he's pushed the pawn and
he's trying to keep that back made
threats alive
would so what if i tried to target that
i see and uh i've got a problem uh
he definitely is looking at h6 as well
right see the
the temptation behind this move exactly
but the problem is
if i have to play knight takes d4 rook
takes d4
we can understand no actually knight
takes before i take and this is what
we've been discussing right this
checkmating
is it a challenge close to checkmate
close to checkmate first of all you
don't have a good way to defend this
knight on d4 so you have to find the way
i play queen e3 not only that i'm
threatening queen to h2 but i also have
an eye on the rook
so that basically cancels your rook on
d1 as a defender of the knight on d4
precisely that's exactly what we were
discussing yeah yeah so now i'm
beginning to really warm up to bishop a6
uh i need to win that control of the c8
square and it's always the title and
he's been thinking for a while because
aside bishop e5 he's on a 20-minute
thing right now whoa dingley wrote 20
minutes
it's a lot he doesn't usually take this
type of deep uh deep things no
uh for me
alejandro one of the things i've really
admired about being
larian is his extraordinary i mean he's
a gifted gifted attacker yes i just
think that i've seen some of his
tactical
uh brevities and i just whoa that is so
good including a victory that he had
over duda i believe in an olympiad which
was just uh remarkable stuff
uh but also a good technical player
yeah he's 2800 for a reason he's good at
all facets of the game his opening prep
is actually very impressive as well he
has had some incredible novelties uh he
is well versed in pretty much every
opening so
he's a very all-around player if you had
to ask me what is the weakness the one
weakness of digloren it really is nerves
it's it's performing when it comes down
to it and i think that's why uh i
thought 2019 singfield cup was such a
big breakthrough for him because he's
beating magnus carlos he beat magnus
carlson in a tie break right uh a lot of
pressure on him to actually do so indeed
but you know when it comes to candidates
tournaments and his performance
it's nice
it's been poor right also the world cups
in general he hasn't out yeah performed
but in olympia when he's playing for
china and he's led the team that's true
he has led the team uh to gold i want to
say twice i think he was in the 2014
tromso squad i'm not sure about that but
i think he was and he was definitely in
the 2018 but to me one that they won
exactly
but we've got some uh questions from our
social media
let me have it from youtube user james
uh these gms are preparing such complex
problems for each other how do they
prepare to handle the surprises they get
from each other
darn good question um
in my time
whenever we got surprised with some huge
novelty it was just
it was the thing we did we just stopped
splash the water on our faces come and
think for 15 minutes
really try to get the zen of the
position and they keep calm yeah right
don't freak out that oh i don't know
what i'm supposed to do no no no that
find the answer there's got to be an
answer there's got to be an answer and
that's what we did
yeah you learn to use all the resources
that you have in your mind at the moment
you probably have more than one thing
you're not
it's very rare that we get fully
surprised right it's more often that you
get to a position that you know more or
less what the computer evaluation is you
know more or less where the ball is
rolling you know more or less what you
can expect from this position like how
far you can stretch it out and how far
uh you know how much risk risk you can
take right so you analyze all that you
put it together as a conglomerate and
you say yeah i'll choose this and you
obviously think a long time uh before
you make such a decision but as far as
the training for it it feels like that's
our entire career like
getting surprised over and over again
and and it's very common during a chess
game that you get surprised by your
opponent's moves i know these are very
top-level players and very often they're
thinking alike
but if i had to say one thing that
surprised me very much when i started
working with my slew players is that
even at the 2600 level
two people would get to the same move
from like completely different paths
right completely different trains of
thought and sometimes they diverge and
then they come up with completely
different ideas and so they surprise
each other during the game all the time
it's just
our mentality that we're constantly
surprised during a game of chess and we
have to readjust
oh absolutely and i i remember uh
kasparov uh he was explaining to me that
in his training
uh with mkeaton nikita would take these
really complex classical
positions and give him 20 minutes
and say okay come up with the best
plans and ideas and he really enjoyed
those challenges because that is
essentially getting surprised he didn't
he didn't prepare for this challenge
that was coming and he was forced to
calculate some really really deep of
course alexander nikiti long time coach
of gary castro passed away last week
yeah very fortunate for the chess world
as he is well one of those unsung stars
right exactly never the front cover of
new enchants but right i mean definitely
one of the most influential coaches in
the history of the game clear no
question about it at all it was actually
quite a i have a funny story of uh nikki
you want to hear this one this was
pretty good
so i'm in moscow and it's the gma
qualifier
to the gma world cup and it was just
like everybody and his brother
was at that event it was an unbelievable
event it was so strong it was
ridiculously strong
immediately after the uh event in moscow
we all got on a specially chartered
plane
and we flew
to
spain
uh
i have to for the gma meeting
so i'm sitting next to gary we're
analyzing a game that we played at sri
leftia
uh the whole flight and i went to the
bathroom and i'm going down the alley of
the bathroom i'm going three grand
masters three grandmasters three
grandmasters
three grand masters
and i go
back to gary and i go gary you're not
going to believe this but like i think
everybody in the top 100
is on the flight so he turns to nikita
and he says go do your research
right
so the guy comes back in about 20
minutes and he says this is missing in
the top 100. jonathan spielman
so gary gets on the intercom he says
okay everybody if the flight goes down
for any reason
jonathan spielman
is the number one player in the world by
50 rating points and he's responsible
for our deaths
and it was like it was it was really
amazing i don't think the insurance
companies like the fact that we were all
on this flight it was pretty impressive
uh i want to turn to fabi and
duda's game for just a moment we just
saw the move king e6 i think it's time
that white gets his majority going how
about king c2 i'm assuming f5
how about b3 uh
and i'm going to pre-move a3 followed by
c4 when i play c4 i don't want you to
play b4 so i'm going to pre-move a3 and
then i'm going to play c4 and try to get
my majority going what do you think of
those apples and if i preemptively
played before you have this intermediate
move bishop c4 check check yes yes
exactly so and then
i get my favorite living condition where
i will be a pawn up
right so you don't get to play b4 but if
you made a passive move rook c7 this is
how i think
um
bobby
it takes them some time it's not like
you can just
push your majority
uh to advantage but if i can get in this
move c4 and
force bishop takes c4 check
then i think he's for choice
um otherwise i don't really see how
white
goes about his business
it does feel kind of forced that at some
point you push your majority right
that's the main plan of the position i
like your idea king c2
i couldn't even consider start with the
move a3 um i don't
don't really know why b3 is never needed
but we have a special guest with us a
good friend of ours is alive from spain
making us all jealous as usual
grandmaster maurice ashley is joining
the fray maurice tell us how is madrid
well if i tell you you're going to get
upset
i'm already upset it's okay
madrid is fantastic the energy here is
absolutely extraordinary
it's just an incredible buzz in the city
and the tournament itself i mean
everybody here is excited about it and
this after all it's a candidate so what
can you
what more can you ask for
uh
maurice i've seen photos of the palace
that these guys are playing in it just
looks
awesome that's got to be one of the
nicest buildings i've ever seen for a
chess tournament
the palace is
palatial
it's incredible i was actually trying to
film from one of the halls so that you
guys would see better backdrop than the
one i've given you right now but the
audio was crazy it was just echoing off
these giants marble walls and and uh but
it's it's incredible it's you remember
loving alejandra
remember it was very echoey when we were
doing it in the studio there in leuven
but you also remember it was a
spectacular venue it was one of our
favorite venues because of the way it
looked and it was the old town hall of
the city but this one is just like
yeah different i'm not going to say it
puts i'm going to say it was love into
shame because you know we got friends
that live in
but wink wink it's pretty damn good
right
maurice como estas uh me amigo
muy bien gracias gracias i i wanted to
ask you tell us a bit about the energy
of the players you're there you can feel
them who has the most positive energy in
your opinion
the confidence i'm seeing that fabiando
exudes is extraordinary i mean he looks
like the guy who's like i've been here
done this i'm trying to get back people
are talking about alareza you know
pumping up other possible names ding
lorraine who was my pick
to do really well here i gladly i didn't
have to pick the way tom forces us to
pick and you know after the first round
i would have said oh no i'm not gonna
pick ding anymore
but fabi is definitely looking like he's
here on a mission and i think he's
playing really well right now
um any insights uh about the players
seconds uh we were very happy to see
mayor lavoyevich a black name from the
past as he arrived with richard rapport
any any other players seconds hanging
out or is it all rather hidden
i haven't seen anyone frankly and i
should say i'm a tourist here i'm not
working you know i'm just hanging out i
haven't had a chance to be a chess
tourist at these events usually you're
setting up and getting ready for work
right uh
so i've only seen chuchulov fabi's
second i haven't seen anyone else it
looks like they're all staying hush-hush
and pretty quiet but again i'm i'm not
allowed into the player's room uh okay i
get the vip treatment but still it's
like now
you can't go in there you can't go in
there so i i don't i haven't had any
insights into those players into the
seconds
and how is the ambiance for the
spectator is it a spectator friendly
event how what's happening outside of
the hall when the tournament is done
absolutely very spectator friendly they
do have this setup where you have
commentators you have the spanish
language commentators giving
very lively commentating
for the spanish-speaking crowd nothing
for the english-speaking crowd after all
we're in madrid but people are just
buzzing around they even have a fan zone
because
the tickets are limited so they have to
have a special area off site for fans to
go that's more boisterous so it's
definitely an event that the chess fans
here are mouth-watering for them they're
just super excited and after all it's
such a huge event for the chess world
that we're all excited to see this
happen maurice you said you're there as
a fan where are you now located where
are you coming from to madrid
well i live in fort lauderdale florida
as you guys know i moved there i had to
go to new york for a special ceremony in
new york so i went there first hung out
with my peeps and then left uh to
directly from jfk to come here to madrid
my trip will keep me here i do have one
big event tomorrow for a chest and a tea
group immortal game that i've signed
with
and then from then i'm going to hang out
a few more days in madrid and then i'm
going to be off to the south of france
where my father and now my son also live
so i'll be in france for a couple of
weeks and then i'm gonna come back to
barcelona for a little bit and then
madrid and then i'm back in the usa
you're a busy man terrible terrible i i
hope you can cope with this tough summer
ahead of you maurice
yeah nice it's good to see that you're
keeping busy and you sure look uh you
look very well my friend
thank you thank you and i do miss st
louis i do miss all of you we miss you
we miss you here commentary with us here
are some of the shots of the palace that
maurice has been talking about as he
explains it's just so spectacular in the
inside of the building
it's gilded
gold everywhere marble and the most
beautiful paintings
incredible you know everything
everything inside is is an instant
postcard it looks gorgeous
and so is everything outside madrid is
gorgeous as a city this is a great place
to walk around people tourists are
everywhere taking photos selfies it's
just an extraordinary place so
you don't get to be a fan too much of
these events when we're working and
we're stuck inside for hours and hoping
to make some time
i've this is my first candidate as well
to even attend so yeah i know yeah so
you're like dude you're not a rookie
what's wrong with you your first
candidate
i can't believe that that's remarkable
you never got a chance to visit the
candidates before this event he was
always working here no
maurice uh we've been doing predictions
as you know and some of them are better
than others doing predictions i'm not
going to name any names now give us your
prediction maurice
like i said i would have said ding liran
i thought he was hungry
the hungriest maybe because of his
horrible result especially from the last
event
his start was really poor though and
so you're asking me to predict after
round three my second favorite was fabi
so i'm gonna have to go with fabi
especially after seeing the way he's
playing at the moment he just looks like
he's really informed i really would love
to see alder raza pull it off frankly it
just the youngin just turned 19. he talk
of the chess world uh the next
big dog in the in our game but he looks
he looks unstable his end games are
looking kind of funny he did get
fortunate in the first two games if he
can pull this one off against nakamura
he'll be back in the hunt for sure but
fabi looks like
the vet that really wants to get it done
maurice thank you so much for taking
time and joining us we really appreciate
you and we miss you
uh but enjoy your summer sounds like
it's going to be a spectacular one
thanks guys keep doing the great work
all righty oh thank you maurice and yeah
that was great to have insights
live from spain of course what a great
playing hall they have it really is it
really is the organization's spectacular
yeah i
always appreciated it whenever i was in
in a playing hall that was
really really remarkable and i remember
a lot of the days of the grand masters
association we had these world cup uh
tournaments and we played in one
cathedral in barcelona
which
my god
it was just like it was just
an amazing
amazing place to play chess and i just i
just felt so good about it it it brings
out i think it brings out the best in
all the players because the players
we love
a full audience
we love the fans coming at us and saying
uh you're my favorite go ahead and do
well and uh when you're in a really
really nice playing hall you just feel
like i'm so happy uh your thoughts
christian guys well i've been looking at
this game between alireza and hikaru
because a lot of things actually
transpired since we last watched this
game and we were looking at the position
after bishop to g5 you guys were
mentioning e5 try to create your own
counter play in the center hikaru
decided and he didn't have a lot of time
to decide on that he decided to launch
an attack on the queen side with the
next few moves c4 g4 but this allows
white to get everything he wanted from
the beginning of this whole setup f3
tried to go g4 try to get the pawn storm
going on the king side g4 b5 rook to d1
and now this asks an immediate question
from black because i have a big threat
your knight is under threat i'm
threatening to take on f5 you cannot
take back because the knight is going to
fall can you defend it with a rook
coming to d8 absolutely not because the
bishop g5 is doing a fantastic job both
defending but also controlling key
squares in black's position so what did
he carry said okay it seems like i have
to go f takes g4 finally i have by the
way f4 would have been a pretty bad move
because after rook to d4 you're just
simply going to lose some uh key
situations right now the pawn on f4 i'm
threatening to go h5 and then take on f4
you're in big big trouble right he took
on g4 f takes g4
and we have the move a5 on the board but
it feels like in the past few moves
black is just throwing black bullets at
white on the queen side nothing is
actually happening i understand you're
gaining a lot of space but you don't
have any active threats at the same time
white managed to get two connected
passers
and that's a big weapon later on in the
future right now if we exchange the
rooks i have a feeling like white might
already be in a winning situation so
let's see where this takes us it does
feel like also the engine is agreeing
with the assessment that white is just
simply increasing his advantage for the
past few moves f1 seems to be the the
main idea king to g6 rook to e1 try to
harass you around your weaknesses and
then slowly slowly improve my position
and get my pawns rolling down
also putting a lot of pressure on his
time a5 was played only 14 minutes to go
still
seven moves to go for a hikaru this one
is um starting to look good for ali reza
and maurice was mentioning he looked
shaky in the first couple of games he
needs a victory with the white pieces
and this would be a tremendous result
for the young alireza
i get everything that you said christian
with the white pieces i feel i'm more
ambitious than what i saw the engine's
number is 07. and i was wondering
in the end of that variation rook f1
king g6 rookie 1 king f7 i actually like
what you've done of re uh rerouting the
rook to e1 specifically to tether the
king but after the move h5 what what is
black doing
you cannot do we have rook g8 see i
thought about rook g8 but after rook f1
check i couldn't find a good move
because if you go back to the e file
kingdom i go h6 and you actually cannot
take my bishop
and i think you might actually just be
lost by force
exactly with mike with your pawn on h6
and my king not
sitting on a g6 i don't like it at all
so you're reckoning hold on just a
second yeah kf7 and h5 uh
king
king f7 h5
i
i guess okay
let's try to go b4 right
i just don't know what white what i i i
feel
what christian said that i do feel like
i am shooting blanks
i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
going to ignore you right i'll go rook i
don't know rook f1 but you're king
enough i'm going to have to stay
i believe i'm going to have to stay
whether like it or not on the king side
so that when you go bishop c1 and that
you eventually go h6 i will have at long
last man
do i have time to go bishop f4 yeah i
love bishop f4 no way you get into that
rook end game right
to connect the passage game is starting
to look shaky you don't have time to get
the king to g5 with the pawn on already
on b4 because the pawn on c4 is hanging
even if you get your pawn to g5 i don't
care i mean king h6 i'm not taking that
pawn i'm going rook f6 i know my end
games two connected past bones don't
need a king
to
force themselves through
uh just a second so go ahead kill me i'm
sure you are i just uh i'm just gonna go
slowly now that i have those two pawns
you can't make a move so i'll just take
on c3 and i'll bring my king in
uh take on c3 so i'll take on a take on
a2 okay
and
if i if i get a block you have six
you don't block it is too much that's
the problem
right now i have another no no i don't
know why would you alright
that's his idea well i will go king of
four
and now that comes the question who's
faster right h6 e5 g5
you're fast it's a race it's a race
i i
i didn't think it was super super easy
it might be uh super easy okay let's go
back one move uh a couple of moves
actually let's take on e6
okay
and then i'll take and you go h6 and
this is just a very nice ending huh i
think so and i think it might just be
one rook c6 would be winning on the spot
if i get that moving well rox c8 is met
by h7 that doesn't and then it is
winning on the spot yes yeah so i think
this is just winning
wow
fair enough um and these are the
challenges that black is facing h5
played immediately because i was
throwing rook f1
in but perhaps it's not needed h5 was
played by ferruja immediately and i
think we're going to go through
something very similar rook f1 seems
like a big threat
it was funny uh the engine wanted to go
rook f1 uh ali reza played uh
h5 what
h5 g8
a move i wanted to play actually sorry
i'll go go back here for just a second
if you don't mind uh again h5 is already
on the board yeah rook f1 was the line
we were just looking at i actually
wanted to play rook d4 yeah why because
i wanted to play h5 and i wanted to be
able to meet the move rook g8 with
bishop c1 and i've got my pawn on g4 but
guys wasn't this the problem that we
discussed with rook g8 rook f1 the one
that hikaru is playing look yes we're
going through the line uh h5 was played
yes rook g8 and
you guys mentioned rook to f1 king e8 is
not possible because of h6 well he
caused about to show us a king e8
h6 played i only move
it on the board yes that's on the board
and
played
rook f8 what a move what a movie caru
wow it's trying to exchange the rooks in
a way
because you've already committed the
pawn to h
you cannot do this if the pawn is on h5
no
no because then i but now i can blockade
the pawn if the rooks come off wow this
is just
living life dangerous edge dangerous
stuff really
oh wow wow
okay but now having said all that i mean
you still well i don't want to trade
rooks now on on a good day i get to go
king here king here and the worst will
be passed
if you go rook h1 i assume i'm gonna go
king f7 i don't
don't see
any reason not to reject yeah uh
so you went to age six you go rook h8 is
that it one of the
one of the great chess teachers i think
is uh michael chisholm
and he wrote this really wonderful book
on the endings and i remember reading it
ages ago and one of the things that he
really
boy emphasized to
a great level that when you do have an
advantage
patiently patiently patient don't rush
h5 h6 uh so again maybe it's because of
adrian that i was thinking you know what
just
slowly slowly
rook here on here
drop the bishop back play for a4
the pawns will be on h5 and g4 my bishop
will be beautifully
situated
but i love the rook f1 and the lines
that you guys were showing this one this
position that we currently have let me
just refresh my board i apologize it
will just be a second
if you don't win right away
you got tricked
you advance your pawns uh too soon i
don't feel that way i feel black is very
awkward on the king side that true it's
not easy for you to actually get the
setups that you want for example if i
play the move rook h1 i'm just trying to
make this work for please rook h1 king
g7 king
all right yes
okay
h7 of course i have to go k rook to h8
with the idea of king g6
it's not so easy actually huh
you tell me uh one of the best moves i
think you could play right now is h6 h5
back on c1 uh jump right in christian
has
hikaru
tricked
no no no his opponent no no that game is
still ongoing still i have a lot of
options uh left on the board both for
white and for black still
the engine and we also think from a
practical perspective it does feel like
white has uh the trumps in at this
position and could potentially go on to
win this one nevertheless there's still
plenty of work
uh
also creative work now let's take a look
at what's happening in the dingly red
versus ritchie report because this one
is exploding and i have to say
white dingley wren that is right now
with 25 minutes on the clock has a
golden opportunity to take over
this game
very difficult
very difficult move but if you think
about it quite logical because very
often black always has in its pocket
this idea of knight ac2 and exchanging
everything and this is what king g7 is
getting ready to because at the end of
all the variation that we've seen so far
rook to d8 doesn't come with a check
anymore so this king g7 improves the
position of the blacking and by the way
how did we get here after bishop e5 this
is where we left it a4 came on the board
reinforcing the defense of the bishop on
a b5
and we have king to g7
if he finds this move king to f1
just
sidestepping
this check attack knight takes e2 but
this comes back to a very very concrete
line knight takes e2 queen takes d8
knight takes c1 everything is looking
okay for black if you take on c1 i take
on e4 and now comes the shocking move
queen to g5 which finishes the game on
the spot
because you have two threats major
threats the bishop on each e5 is one of
them which is going to lead to
checkmates and another variation that's
going to lead to almost a checkmate h6
h6 boxing the king on the eighth rank
followed by rook to d8 that's all she
wrote game over
material wise black right now is ahead
but unfortunately unable to defend all
of these threats for example if you play
queen to e4 h6 finishes the game rook
checkmate
big big moment right now if he finds
king to f1 dingley wren is in poor
position to score his first victory at
the candidates 2022 edition i'm sorry
king f1 is just that would be so
low
on that's the money move right
on my
list of moves what would be higher
well bishop a6 uh
you don't play a bishop a634
of course rook c4 is a move i would be
uh thinking about at least in this
position even if it's good or not
uh king f1 does not come connect but
rickshaw is just a blunder right
knight f3
that is actually pretty funny i take
with the pawn you take my queen yeah and
i even though your queen is hanging my
rook is hanging on d1 right right oh
that is crazy let's put that on the
board rook c4
very nice hidden tactic
knight f3 check check it out that's the
money move
all right rook takes and rook takes and
rook takes and suddenly it's over it's
just winning for black
wow okay so and because i think i think
what what what because you get rook c4
and dingler is pretty strong yeah you
say rook c4 i saw that in two seconds
the university is in half right
he says rooks before i have three loses
right oh let me move my king
i mean you come to
these moves like what you're saying
about your students you give them this
position and they go through completely
two different
gyrations and they get to the same
answer right like how did you do that
how did you figure that out um and so
you think okay rook c4 i'm always
terrible yeah knight f3 check uh kill oh
let me get my king out of the way
wow king f1 again uh
not the first move on my radar i mean
what can i say queenie three
h quickly
i definitely would understand
yeah queen e3 i like the problem is that
maybe king f1 is just so much stronger
stronger yeah but then again i need to
go i wasn't there
right now
on e2 we exchange everything and take on
e4 how is that so is it say it again
christian
just i'm trying to understand the merits
of this move queen to e3
you take with the bishop and you want to
go h6 correct but even if you go h6 i go
king f6 so let's start with the rule d1
it's casually thrown out
all right
queen takes e4
queen takes let's try it out like this
and if you go h6 i'm going to go king f6
wow
and again this might be one of those
endings where peter spidler
a grunfeld expert who loves sacrificing
exchanges uh with his pawn majority
would say hey man a three result game i
like black yeah okay because the pawn on
h6 actually it was actually very weak
right the king f1
wow i again for me i find that move uh
really elusive i
wouldn't
well on my list of candidate moves it
just wouldn't especially since uh you
get you got the uh calloused to the idea
of knight takes e2 and all these checks
not being that threatening right so
you're not even thinking about getting
rid of knight ec2 with the check
that much right that's why you don't go
king to f1
um and he's thinking for the last 15
minutes this is a big moment he senses
it
perhaps we're going to seek into f1 and
if we do
then richie might be in some danger out
of curiosity it does feel like it's just
the worst move but why why why not to h1
sorry why not to h1 because once again
now we have this idea of queen to e7 i
think so h1 came to e7 queen to h4 is
coming i'm starting to tickle you on
that uh on that forgot about that yeah
yeah so uh sorry c4 was was that played
no that was my blunder uh king f1 and i
just wanted to see this line again
because it is really hidden i mean i
just wanted when could you say is that
that
you know if you don't go one ply deeper
right here
and you stop and you go well rook takes
c1 queen takes e4 what am i doing i'm an
idiot i i i i've really helped my
opponent black
establish a very good position for
himself
but if you see this move queen g5 and
you go oh
look at that how exciting is that i'm
attacking the bishop i've got this mate
i wanted to ask you uh christian is this
uh
uh
because
pardon h6
king g8 i think i got queen f6
and you're pressing me wait wait wait
wait why why can't i go e5 actually
because i want to mate you i don't see
you like the defense is gonna i'm just
gonna meet you on g7 that's a good point
yeah yeah yeah so you don't take my
knife i don't think anything here right
yeah
this is nasty queen h you don't have
chucks queen queen g7 which sounded just
made right yeah
wow great stuff queen g5 is a real
cold shower and i was trying to make
queen h4 work but queen h4 with the same
idea of h6 but that's just one threat so
i can just easily parry it with h6 and
actually this blacklist better after
this so queen g5 is the critical move
the key move in the position that
unlocks or the possibility to uh pretty
much give the checking
wow with the double threat of queen
takes e5 followed by or
and or h h5 h6
turns the tables
in uh white's favor that is
and the king has f1
right yeah that's crazy too the king on
f1 yeah king f1 is actually really safe
the bishop on b5 is nicely protected
we've got no checks 21 moves
played 19 moves to go and only 17
minutes
no increment remember no increment
well that's a lot of moves actually
that's 21. it seems like this grundfeld
develop develop develop but it actually
develops slowly very slowly right yeah
it was all of this theory for quite some
time and then bishop g5
hmg5 novelty was three moves ago
it feels like
he's done it
he played it 2800 for a reason yasser
king f1 20-minute think almost and he
found it
wow
he is a machine christian i was curious
actually we saw a lot of variations in
which uh black just loses right how does
he continue the game well that's the
queen to e7 probably is the best move in
the position right now just uh trying
some somehow to pull the brakes but now
i can just take advantage of the pin and
play queen to e3 right can i play h6
first or something you can yes uh h6 i
would take actually but i thought i was
winning
between
three queen g5 and then f4 at the end is
that what no no i want to play uh knight
takes d4
instead of queen takes g5 and i forgot
that at the very end of this line my c1
rook is hanging right ah i understand
yeah yeah yeah
oops i forgot about that yeah so
i guess that's not as good um
it's still pretty decent even this
position after take take and now g3
still pauses
f4 sorry what happened with that f4
check oh f4 i think the rook on c1 is
hanging at the end right well why do you
keep forgetting that it's the same rook
it's a curse
i mean you can still go here but now i
really really take the two before
because you have knight f3 and take off
yeah you take on d4 first i take on d4
first and then
not that bad nice more or less active
yeah oh no this is kind of three results
but this is i i mean look king f1 comes
as a cold shower and that gives 2.6
until he gets used to the shock of this
move that gives dingley ran a few
minutes to actually think about
the options for black to defend this
potentially find queen to e7 and prepare
his response because for the next
20 uh 20 moves almost 20 moves 19 moves
that is he's going to have to play fast
really really fast he will have to make
his decision fast and this is not the
last game by any stretch of the
imagination for uh richie rapport under
the current circumstances and i'm
placing the time situation in high
regard right now
thank you for that and this is their a
lifetime head-to-head score not a lot of
games seven draws a lot of draws two
wins for dingler and one for richie i
don't really remember that without the
fair measure of one another but we have
some social media absolutely requests uh
quizzes and questions thank you for
joining the conversation what do you got
for us
let's take a look and this one is from
uh youtube james yeah calculating
complex positions over the board like in
the car game are mentally tiring how do
players cope with it it's an excellent
question training
uh yeah training training training uh
physical training specifically uh if you
are a professional chess player there is
no two ways about it you will be doing
physical training as much as you don't
like to do it right some people love
doing it magnus loves doing it right it
helps him tremendously but you need the
stamina but you need the stamina it's
absolutely mandatory to have the stamina
during games you train all calculating
to get used to the fact that you're
calculating for hours but you also run
you also run do sports uh everybody has
their own
little thing but it really does come
down to physical conditioning yeah
exactly for me was tennis i actually
really liked the game and it was uh
it just seemed that wherever i went
there was a tennis court
that's also true it also feels like that
we were playing at a lot of hotels and
tournaments and some of them have tennis
courts exactly exactly well during our
time actually with fabiano and most of
the camps with tennis was a big part of
our schedule as well and i'll give you
an insight about that
i don't want to boost this ego too much
but christian went from being easily the
worst
that's not true
by the end of the world championship
it's just hand-eye coordination with the
racket right once he got that down
yeah
merry christmas
uh i i have a theory i i get
pretty decent very fast after that i
just plateau in every single game and
trust me trust me that fabian i pretty
decent
will be a very strong word
yeah he's his serve he's very tall his
serve is really really hard to return
hate that josh wait
no not josh wait um josh joshua he's
very good very very good at tennis right
right robert
man
actually was on the harvard tennis team
okay that's serious that is very serious
yeah oh boy
sorry one quick there was this wonderful
tournament in lone pine california it
was an open event
and uh it had a very strange schedule it
was like five games of play
two free days in a row back to back
followed by four rounds of play
this was to accommodate sami rashevsky's
uh religious
sabbath
and during these two days of play there
was this wonderful gymnasium basketball
court and she had all of these players
chess players playing basketball
and there was this one guy and i forgot
his name it was very shameful but he
really looked like the perfect cpa the
the glasses the
missing hairline
the whole thing nobody wanted to play
him i choose him on the team finally he
was allowed to play and he was a ucla
he was a part of the ucla basketball
team so this guy guy hit like six
three-pointers in a row
and we were like
what the heck is this
a rigger
wow from recent nba players i think
that's very similar uh the way you
describe it to caruso
caruso from the bulls right now he used
to play for la he came from the g league
he wasn't really a touted prospect and
then he became like a really strong
player right now
wow cool guys
we have huge updates in the car game the
hicario game is is very important
because uh we're going into forcing line
he's actually trying to wrestle there as
a house after the move rook f8 yeah he
takes takes bishop d8 is currently on
the board i assume that if you give up
my the a5 point you're dead so you have
to wait
um isn't it i'm just trying to make a
draw okay right we do understand that
right right black is making a draw yes
this is clear
um okay so because i'm just so happy to
get this blockade in so go a4 first well
no no but bishop d2 is is i don't think
you survived this
why would you give up a point i survived
no but you can go a4 and do the same
thing hold on g5 i don't have to go uh
you can go g5 yeah i think so yeah
oh my goodness oh my goodness
i would never imagine this is a fortress
but why do you want to go to this
position when you
okay
so what's alireza's idea after a4 then
pause
i'm hearing crickets over here guys come
on
i don't know yesterday
at some point he's gonna try to get his
king to e4 right so he has to go all the
way to f3 now the question is how do you
get there king to c2 is met by knight to
e3 you cannot do that
oh well not so clear to me king c293
it's kc293 king c3
yes you pick up g4
but i can always defend my other pawn
with um with bishop g5 and i start to
wonder
yeah i don't want to
let my king in right
i'm thinking the danger excuse me i'm
thinking the danger for me
is uh
if i give up the queen side
uh
and i win the king side that's more
dangerous than the question you're not
on the king side where i'm blockading no
no so i'm not going after this guy
i will go
you just block it right yeah you you go
ahead and you bring your king if you
like and you're either
worse yeah exactly do your worst and
should i play b4 or c3 i think i'm going
to completely find his black here so if
your case let's get the bishop to d2
first okay
so that's fine you can get all the way
to king e2 yeah that's true actually you
go bishop a5 and you go bishop d2 but
you can go all the way to king e2 i want
to get the king to e2 first because the
bishop feels like it's in the way of the
king no no i have the timing you have
the timing because if you do it the
other way around i'm attacking the pawn
on h6 you don't have the time to do that
i have bishop g5 so just a second so if
you like king c2 i like king f7 and
bishop g5 here bishop g5 here uh
christian sure all right i guess you can
go bishop g5 next move too any move
actually you cannot
why and i go bishop to d2
and
this do you want to put the pawn on e4
all right let's put the pawn on e4 also
right five and e4 i just feel like i'm
so close to some kind of a fortress here
i mean how is your king making every
progress ever gonna disturb so now i go
k7 king g6 you you do what you want
well it's not that easy because uh
when i do get my king to g4 you'll have
to either move your knight or your king
right or i go e3
so just so let's let's wait and see all
right
you got all the way to g4 this is the
ideal situation
uh
wow so bishop you won not at all
incoming
[Laughter]
i have got to say by the way uh ikaru's
end game yesterday that he had against t
moore and the determination and grit
that he showed to win that i thought
he'd be exhausted to suddenly have
another
yes uh super hard
the very next day i think after king g4
let's let's stay with that because it's
quite instructive
king g4 i go b4
boy
now if you take i go a3
a3 or c3 or c3 i think c3 i think so
is better yes yes both of them i think
we
well i'm getting nervous exactly
yeah
and this feels lost yeah i think i think
i overdid it but that's why i didn't
play c3 so let's go no no but c3c2 i i
don't see any problems i think you just
go c2 you pick up my bishop with netflix
before knight d3 yeah i'm not making any
progress b5
b5
no no but i think a3 just wins by force
uh sorry uh chris that was your first
intention
because this forces you to take okay
and now i go e3
now you go e3 right
i don't think you're in time to do what
unless you can sacrifice the bishop of
course i'll sacrifice the fish
when i sacrifice the bishop i think
about winning i'm not thinking about a
draw no i think i go bishop one and i
sacrifice one and then sacrifice on c3
yeah right
right and then i have a bunch of pawns
that's weird this is winning for white
uh the the worm turns yes i
don't know what that means but i assume
the sunny side of the torture is now on
my uh
my side of the board wow uh what an
ending guys that is just uh
great stuff but
i really got a feeling
why is he carnal moving do you see guys
do you see any move that's not a4 he's
in the think tank
no but he only has two moves left so
that's okay for him so a4 has to be
played a4 has to be played right i i
don't know i actually paused because i
was thinking if i could trade off the a5
pawn for the h6 bond i i i would be very
very happy but the problem is i can't i
don't have the timing to do it a4s only
move yep and save the pawn
the bishop attacks the ball and the pawn
has to be defended i mean that's
a4 finally played uh i don't know why he
didn't play a little bit faster but he
only has a couple of minutes luckily for
him only a couple of moves left yeah
who's 38 he just has to make move 3940.
let's jump in quickly to the game of
bobby for just a moment because this is
a game that we
thought yeah we left it a while ago wow
but fabi did the one thing i didn't want
him to do
i didn't want him to play c4 when b4
when b4 was the answer i wanted to play
b3 a3 c4
and
look what he's done to his bishop
why did he do that
uh isn't duda just much better
h3
bishop h3 now yes right i mean i have to
do something
okay i didn't know what your bishop is
actually doing on h3 i was hoping i go
to g4
you got a death wish a little bit but on
the other hand i don't think you can
okay yeah i got knight c5 check
i'm i'll go king e3 i just don't don't
see that issue
what
real
no
seriously no i'm just kidding
i got two connected
i have two false points too
they're not connected which is even
better
um
just a second
uh you're cruising for a bruising dude
uh
my knight on
and on c5 is a monster it's killing
white's queen side majority
and if i get to play e4 it's lights out
if you take on g5 you're on time right
exactly yeah actually yeah this doesn't
feel so easy all right so let's go back
to the position because he's played king
d3
and we're looking at knight b7 right
absolutely so the other option would be
if it's not bishop h3 it's c5 directly
but i was worried that c5 you got not
knight take c5 allowing king c4 king d5
but did you just play the move knight
king d5 right away
yes exactly uh you block you block my
entrance first
six i can actually give you a check yeah
you give me a check and then i take on
c6 and then life is very very good good
but this is the worst setup
possible right for fabian's point of
view is you put a black knight on c5 and
a black bottom b4
and
it's a two result game i'm sorry it's
just a very let me do this a little bit
more clever okay bishop h3 i still think
has to be it and then g4 as well
check and let me not go to e3 let me go
somewhere like e2 where it's not getting
checked by g2 or d2
e2 e2 yeah okay
so at some point what are you going to
do there okay i need to put you in my
knight
no i don't need to put my knight there
sorry just second
jump in christian i i feel like i got a
fish on the hook here but uh
i agree i agree and to be honest i don't
like this bishop h3 i was
preferring bishop d3 bishop c2 the
passive defense see this is where i
thought the game becomes three results
why because i don't take h5
or h5 right away i don't know
take take h5 yeah so i get to
i get to stop
your pawn
so let's get you guys to go king e3
h6
actually let's go king f6 first
king e3 and now king d5
uh king g5 or king king e5
wow
i don't want to allow you to go to d4
but i was thinking
are you afraid of king d4 take c5
like
yeah
well don't the pawns go marching in
marching where but don't i start with h6
first wait wait a second yes sir don't i
start with h6 ah you start yeah i'm
sorry you're right of course you do yeah
h6 f4 king d4 and now that's right i
think you're in some trouble yeah h6
first sorry you're right absolutely
right
um
okay i'm just now but guys let's still
go to king e5 let me just uh update uh
the current position in this game of
fobbies for just a moment i just gotta
read that position
and this is
uh
let's go back to the hikaru game it's
incredibly tactical really yes all right
let's do it uh i'm just saying that i'm
rather stunned that bobby played that
way
me too me too i i am stunned and and i
think i we finally will understand what
hikar was thinking so long a4 a g5 was
played king f7
h6 h7 h7 and it's funny that you say
it's incredibly tactical with only a
couple of pieces major uh final pieces
on the board right true complicated but
zombo c3 seems to be forced right well
exactly but now there's only
white has a dream
all he wants to do is put his light a
dark square bishop on this a long
diagonal but for the moment all the
squares that the bishop
can maneuver to
somehow it's not so easy for him to get
there
should i be playing for
uh why not bishop
history was plato's barely the only way
if i take on c3 what do you do
you wanted to wha why are we rejecting
bishop h4 oh i don't know yet we're not
you know i mean uh all i have a dream i
just want to put my bishop on e5 but now
don't i have knight f4
what no no bishop six knight four
so i cannot move that knife well that's
a problem
correct your threat right now is bishop
g3 i guess i have to go e5
e5 and knight f4 if you go bishop g3
wow
and if i take on c3 what a tactical
smartest bishop knight takes jesus no no
if i take on z3 before uh bishop g3
take on c3 before being fight
i'm sorry what e5 e5 take on c3
e5 take on c3 thank you take on c3 right
that's a check
king knight c5
okay wherever you go knight back knight
back to d5
d3
uh
do i want to play bishop here oh then
you're going to go knight f4 yeah yeah
and then you go b4 got you yeah give me
king d3 what is the what is the defense
here and b3 king knight
can i no but here i take okay and i go
a3 oh you can also win
forget about that
no wait wait wait wait no no but you're
not winning this no you're not waiting
but you're threatening to win you're
threatening to win which means i'm
forced to go back with my bishop no no
but wait this might be winning for white
is it g3 i don't know i mean i do have
the b pawn
you don't have a weapon no no you played
a3 no you played a3 if you take them
before you go king e4 and you don't have
time to return bishop g3
how how do you so
how did you do it after g3 right now
bishop gt3 bishop g3
bishop g3 oh my
so then king summer i i'm not sure where
i think c2 but
let's go b5 no no let's go e5 let's go
right i don't have time
to catch your pawn i i don't need to
catch your pawn
it doesn't my knight that's just a draw
yeah it's my knight
the knight gets back so b6 keep going b6
97 right you get to c6 i get that yes um
but is that enough so let's go king b3
right now okay as this is not even close
right take on a3
g6 king a4
can you have five can be
five yeah and you're putting that on
yeah it might be eight now
last move yeah it should be sufficient
right right i've got my king yeah that's
a wonderful i still have a palm as well
yeah that is a decoy well you need it
right
especially this really comes down to the
wire oh uh you know
guys you felt it was tense yes
breaking news whoa knight takes e2 was
played in the ding game and ding did not
take on d8
he has missed he did not take on g5
knight takes c1 queen to g5 maybe they
were looking at queen takes a win
i i'm trying to understand what and i
would assume that queen takes e4 perhaps
was the one that he was concerned about
but bishop takes c2 okay you take i hide
where's your next check it's not enough
right
it's not even close don't think so so
you cannot play this one because queen
to e4 perhaps is some sort of a
perpetual
uh but king to d2 bishop to f4 king to
c3
my goodness what is happening here you
don't have time
to take on c1 because your between is
hanging first of all
uh so no but
you don't have any checks queen h3 is
going to be met by rook to d3 queen to
e4 i can always just go queen to d4
actually 24 is not so perhaps queen to
e4 is the move right now queen to d4 is
mad by bishop e5 and then you're in
trouble
um
but still
he did not spend how much time did he
spend on this
he played it immediately immediately
queen takes c2 was played automatically
in like 40 seconds
queen takes d8 and perhaps he just
missed that move queen to g5
would have been blowing rapport off the
board oh wow
uh
still up an exchange still up on
exchange but it's not just this is not
the same this is no not at all
uh on d4 go e5 next move cement the
i can put opportunity
bishop on uh d4 and good luck winning
that yeah no we've we've spoken about
how difficult it is to win a game at
these candidates and when you do have an
opportunity like richard had yesterday
uh against perugia and wow
wow like ding ding had a moment ago
wait a minute
is rapport returning the favor
a6 why would you trade the bishops
excuse me so why would you trade the
bishops
you have to take on what
i i
queen takes e4 i completely
it feels like black could just die right
in this descent game i have one party
you have one pawn
bishop maybe on d4 can i anchor my
bishop can i get to play
i mean
g3 right
i just don't let you get to d4 and you
lose the vpn it seems like this is
actually pre a6
a6 that is good how is this end game the
question is right they get your bishop
but even if you get your bishop to c5
then i have rook to b5 and then a5 okay
guys you don't have to calculate then
you don't you don't win that uh though
christian uh bishop and three pawns
versus rook and two forms how do you get
there
we're talking about
a bishop coming to c5 and he was
mentioning rook to b5 and a5 but this is
the problem
what you win the bishop not the pawn
you win the bishop
no i was i don't want to lose my
business
no you don't understand
i want my bishop give me my vision
oh man he's completely lost right now
bishop takes a6 queen takes
you have to keep the queens on you have
to take on e4 and queen to e2 has to
keep
uh black has to keep the queens on the
board queen to f5
but then i take take king g1 or g3 the
thing is i don't i don't think you hold
the same game no obviously the dream of
this particular position what christian
has on this board on a good day i get to
play bishop d4 and e5 yeah i figure i
can hold
that you're just doing that how do i get
how did you do
d4 right because your king is pretty
weak and the thing is you remove the a
pawn and the b pawn and it's a draw but
players are playing your variation
christian yes right into it um yeah yeah
into e4 is on the board we expect queen
to e2 but ding is going to be thinking
about his options
um does he have any other options maybe
rook to e1
yeah rook 21 is a move but this allows
the queen to stay connected to the pawn
on a4 maybe not that convincing also
perhaps bishop d6 bishop c5 creating
this battery might be a problem yeah
queen to e2 just sort of plays itself
right because it forces the queen to a
very passive square exactly uh
if you
quinto f4 it just helps me right it just
helps me g3 is useful it's actually how
to it just helps me yeah yeah
so you put it on f5 but i don't think
you wanted your queen on f5 no it wasn't
the dream uh so we exchange
and i like slow slowly playing it out
king g1 g3
and
two result galleries i don't think so i
think it's one one result game really
it's that
i mean wow i just don't think you keep
the people if you kept the b-pawn
kudos if you got the bishop to d4 not
only that but if you leave the queen uh
on the board i will be able to somehow
maneuver my pieces on the seventh rank
rook d7 will be seven queen d7 and then
pressure uh you on the f7 square as well
you have too many weaknesses the b6
weakness as well as potentially the f7
weakness wow um great stuff guys uh i
want to turn our attention to another uh
minor piece game uh bishop versus knight
uh fabi uh i really really really have
not liked how fabi has played this
ending i don't know how bad it is i know
it's good for black how bad is it or how
good is it
in your opinion um
alejandro
well the producer just yelled at my ear
zero i also felt it was closer to a draw
than anything else i didn't feel it was
zero zero wow
from a practical perspective i mean zero
actually
it is zero zero right you go f5 v4 is
black and you don't make progress
so how do you make progress as black
exactly
so at some point
i'm going to have to play the move a5 a4
force you to
split your pawns happily
create a weakness on a2 and then which
isn't going to be i want to play knight
to c okay come on so let's go e4 f4
let's go
let's go oh you want to go eight hours
you'll take that all right let's go
and uh by the way uh for our folks
watching this is exactly what grand
masters do right
they put down
my opinion is white's better no
i'm better and
this is how uh we analyze
knight takes a4 i'm
my dream
gift meet upon you have a lot of dreams
yesterday
[Laughter]
you never forget
[Laughter]
the american dream made america great
all right if i go something like king d3
just to put a move out there
no i i've got a weakness
how
you're gonna go king d4 and c5 huh yes
i'm actually kind of happy when you take
kind of not happy also because my phones
are split right on the other hand i you
get access to the d4 square and then we
fight for three results
and i hope not
maybe we do maybe we do maybe we don't i
hope for
just a second
i'm trying i mean this is going to be uh
quite the race right uh
yeah but i got the night but is it the
race because not a race i think
it gets flushed out of the c8s
you actually don't give up on night if
you gave up your night you'd be happy
but i just won the full queen i forced
your knight out of the way
uh and sorry uh right here and this
uh race is just simply bad
i like how christian went through that
explanation that rookie one was worse
than queenie two and then didn't
immediately play rookie one
but i learned so much with that
explanation uh
right here guys let's go back we go back
to knight c5 check i'm assuming you're
gonna go king e3
yeah i mean i'm not playing for a win
let's be very clear oh no of course not
uh no black is the one playing for the
win but the question is
uh
can he dad let's say i play f7 f6 just
uh i have another dream now
uh christian mentioned that i have lots
of dreams
uh good turn and nightmares that's your
uh
dream for today i think it
okay
if i keep a pawn on e5
white's king will be
all right let's try to do some awesome
magic of our own okay
what would you like bishop
bishop edgar too he's gonna go f5 on you
well at some point you have to right now
black has to play five at some point
otherwise white ghosts have five
themselves like if you go okay
i think f5 might be you dirty rat things
okay just a second king of five let's
have some fun
on a good day i wonder who's having
who's having fun i don't know uh i think
you're the only one that's having fun
right now
as in black i don't believe that
so much three or bishop let me just take
one
e5
if i achieved so much that's black right
as black i i was hoping that somehow i
would tether your king can i have bishop
f3 your your knight's actually no no no
go g4 no go g4 go g4 why not boy every
time you
you you improve my pawn structure i feel
like i'm
making more and more more progress but
it might not be i need to exchange all
all of this so i can i can get my pawn
to out or i can get my dream oh come on
guys you get the dream right now i feel
like shaq mammy dark come on
what are you guys talking this is easy
winning get out of here okay
bishop e2f4 check actually no
no i like bishop it's fine king d2 yeah
king f3 here king okay so first of all
if i go
uh splashing over here that's one idea
right for me there's no way that wins
but okay i'm going to go for the more
mundane prosaic however you call it all
right bishop g3
bishop to d3 knight here you should
thanks g6 bishop takes g6 for a winner
for our loss i don't
uh
okay um
tiredness has crept into your it has
been six and a half hour days twice in a
row third round we are in for a long
tournament but even we will need our
breaks and let's remember this schedule
we have three rounds of chess and then a
rest day and why because these games are
grueling yes uh not just for the players
clearly for the commentators as well
so we're gonna take a break we're gonna
take a little bit of a break we'll be
right back after a few minutes to keep
up with all of the action plenty to play
for here in round number three don't
miss a beat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we have breaking
news during our break we did have
another result as you see there due to
the standings richard rapport and loren
have added half a point each to their
scores they split the point which has to
be an absolutely miserable result for
the chinese player clearly in a
commanding position clearly with the
better end game and he allowed richard
rapport simply to put that bishop on d4
which we said you just can't do that and
anchor it with e5 which is exactly what
happened in the game ended in the draw
this really hurts for dignity
with that busting novelty of bishop g5
that got him such an advantageous
position so he uses one of his best
novelties in the event gets a winning
position lets us slip out of his grass
and the chinese player for three rounds
is really floundering early yeah
absolutely yesterday's game he felt that
he still managed to get an okay position
against duda wasn't the most convincing
but it was a draw which is fine but his
uh result in round one against nepo
absolutely terrible right and even
though a draw against rapport is usually
okay right but you're not not from the
position of strength yeah
and uh well with that draw uh opens up
the opportunity for fabby how's fabby
doing
yeah five is actually down a pawn at the
moment but am not actually sure that
he's wars at all uh somehow he's
actually just gotten rid of his pawn on
c4 and
he just played c5 i saw that that pawn
bothered him
and the other breaking news of course is
that when we went on our break uh
alireza was having a very nice thing and
he still is and he still is he's not
going anywhere uh he
he's been at the think tank for uh quite
a while now when i say over five minutes
yeah
why
is he
in uh such a think tank we on our break
we we were just saying okay i wanted to
play the move bishop g5 just let's see
yes the whole idea what i want to do of
course is i want to get my bishop on
this diagonal and i asked you
during our break
did you want to take on b2 and i said
well yeah you said yeah i do
and i said well that does help me open
up the diagonal so if we for example put
these moves on the board you can see
that i do want to play a bishop shack
and i do want to bring my bishop back
and around
for the moment
you have any bishop move knight e7 and
it just feels like you know
ikaro is holding on but just like by a
tempo that's all you need though okay
what is your plan though
so
at the moment i'm facing the desirable
bishop c1 so okay uh let's say you go
king aj
yeah and if i go bishop c1 this is where
you i have time you give me the time to
play the knight to e7 because the knight
on d5 is controlling f6 it keeps the
bishop out right when the bishop doesn't
threaten to go to f6
and
coming to see that was also why the pawn
being on the e5 is so crucial
yeah because when i do play them if the
pawn remains on e6
and
for example if you just drop back with
the king and i move my king and then you
drop back again with the king if the
pawn remains on e6 that gives me the
tempo i need
to reroute my bishop to the long
diagonal and that's all she wrote once i
get bishop b2 so you do need to defend
with the move e5
and
intuitively that's a move that you want
to play anyway yeah you need to block
this diagonally intuitively if you get a
bishop check from there the game is over
right uh the thing is i just don't see
how white makes any progress
unfortunately for white if you get your
king too far all the way
you got to be a little careful that you
don't run into a b4 but you get wrong
footed
bishop uh
well jumping followed by bishop c1 i
think this was your initial idea right
yes uh c2
yeah what king c2 followed by bishop c1
bishop b2 like no no in in that position
the one that you have on the board
so how c2
and bishop c1 and that was the what we
were saying
in 97 is just in time
uh and you are hitting a g6 and black is
winning and if i go king d3
then you wait for me or do you go i just
immediately i could wait
personally i would want to get him
before he but he's knocking c4 and if i
take a3 we went through these lines
right wait what no no i go king c4
king c4 yeah
what i mean well this one is checkmate
actually i am giving you a checkmate ah
because i put my keynote no but it
doesn't really matter all right what
about the partner game like if you got
king d3
okay sorry i i apologize just a second
yeah i know we're here we're going can
you see two chad can you see tweaking d3
yeah
now
knight f
four check
you have to i have to take because the
pawn on g6 is hanging
now
rairo uh i'm
your bridesmaid let's keep going k4
what are we going for here
and if i go king f5 you go f3
i'm just
that's a problem
i'm one move away
but that's enough
my turn
no yeah it's not your turn
wow wow
okay
and somehow we managed to make it a
three result game yeah power to us
um
okay well these this is why that's why
he's spending 40 minutes on the clock
but guys before we get into these end
games because we will have a lot of time
to analyze them let's see what happened
in the game between dingley ren and
richie rapport because
we left it off here and this was the
critical moment right when he played
this move king to f1
great move the winning move in the
position especially if you see queen
takes d8 but
he also spent almost 20 minutes
on k2f1 so he dropped from 35 minutes to
17 minutes 18 minutes and a little bit
more than that knight takes e2 and
immediately he played queen takes e2 he
did not even calculate that i feel he
was pressured by his clock situation
right now and he was just trying to make
easy fast decisions that's why he played
the move queen to e2 which is dropping a
lot of its advantage but then he was
given another golden opportunity with
the move a6 take on a6 sure we exchanged
this queen to e4 this is where we left
it off went on a break and i think rook
to e1 was played which was
not a great move and we were
understanding after playing with the
position a little bit that
what needs to be done right now one is
to be targeted for white is the
placement of the black queen we have to
get it on a passive square right with
the move queen to e2 this is exactly
what would have happened because once
again if you exchange this end game
unfortunately is completely lost for
black you don't have enough squares on
this diagonal to protect the pawn on b6
once you put the bishop on c5 with the
king either on c4 or on b5 i will play
the move a5 and you will not be able to
recapture on a5 because the [ __ ] pawn
c5 is going to be hanging so that's a
problem you cannot go ever into this
engage so
after queen to e2 you have to go queen
to f5 and after take take now once again
focusing on
the passive position of the queen i'm
going to go king to g1 slow play you
don't have any threads i'm going to be
able to arrange
my pieces in the optimal uh way and win
the game
now
he played rook to e1 queen to d4 queen
to e2 bishop to f6 and now spent by the
way at this point he had 10 minutes and
38 seconds
not a lot of time especially when you
have still 14 moves to go
uh and he played after a two minute
thing dropping all the way to eight
minutes h takes g6 which once again is a
questionable decision so the queen is
active on d4 right now this is a plus
for black but white still has a lot of
weapons at its disposal one of them
being
that i have this still on the board the
pawn on h5 and i have the option of
potentially getting it to h6
that's going to put a lot of pressure on
the position of your king so for example
what the best move would have been at
this point
is queen to e4 harassing black with this
queen trade we know that if you do take
on e4 and take on h5 once again the end
game is completely lost you will not
have enough squares on this diagonal to
defend the pawn on b6 you will lose this
and if you lose the pawn on b6 you lose
the game
so you have to keep the queens on the
board you have to go queen to c5 once
again now becomes
this move queen to f3 on the board and
now we understand why i was saying that
the pawn on h5 is
a weapon because
h6 is a big threat right now
if you wait if you play just something
like queen to 85 h6 wins on the spot
you're going to lose the bishop on f6 so
if you give a check king to g1 and take
on h5 the problem is right now that the
king becomes weak and i have two targets
to focus on the pawn on b6 and your king
you will be unable to defend both of
them and you just won a pawn on h5 but
one on h5 doesn't matter it's actually a
liability the fact that you had to take
and open up the g file
unfortunately he did not do this and
after exchanging these points the
position for a black skin is too safe
and i will be able to re-route the
bishop to d4 supported with e5 this is
exactly what we got into the game and
that forces the the exchange sacrifice
on d4 which is just going to lead to a
draw and this is what you guys have been
discussing quaint to g4 by the way
don't take on d4
boom queen to h1 shocker cold shower
resign go back uh probably to china
actually at this point i mean you just
lost
two games with the white pieces you're
probably gonna go home um he did not do
that queen to g4 of course he did not do
that e5 uh rook takes d4 and by the way
this is move 37 and uh he was dropping
down to his last minute 58 seconds at
this point no increment he had to make a
decision he made the practical decision
take on d4 you understand that once you
allow the bishop one d4 well it's
probably going to be a draw and this is
the result that we have this is a
disappointment
for dingley wren right now who had
his first victory in his hands and it
just evaporated
you said disappointment and there are
degrees of disappointment uh
i would have been very
uh
forlorn
that i have lost
i i i used a beautiful novelty uh i
caught a big fish if you will and i
didn't secure a victory this was
alejandro this was his moment right
moment he had such a winning position
objectively right he had a position that
he knew
he played this variation with black and
white he knew his opponent went wrong
yeah and then he just failed to
calculate properly i mean yeah he failed
to really understand how good his end
game was or his technique in the ending
was pretty bad
but he also could have just calculated
out queen takes the eight and queen g
and queen g5 is not a difficult move for
him to find i've seen him find much much
more
yeah
variations uh that this game with the
fact that uh ding
pardon me that richard was able to put
his bishop on d4 anchor it with the move
e
five uh again uh reminds me the story of
gary kasparov he plays into the
spartakia olympiad in the soviet union
he adjourns in the positions he's an
exchange down for bishop and pawn he
calls his mentor
michael vodbinic
i'm adjourned i have a pawn for the
exchange but and he hasn't
given the position yet to bod bin egg
and bob says does your bishop is your
bishop anchored he says no you says gary
you're lost
and it was that simple and here you see
uh the power of the anchored bishop by
richard once he got bishop b4 and e5 all
of his troubles was behind him and i
must say uh for richard
three draws but really eventful draws i
mean
it could be a
one of
i mean it's amazing
what he could be at i mean he could be
tied for the lead had he beaten farouja
yesterday as well
and uh what do we got now with the
hikaru game we didn't see it still by
the way absolutely nothing no
we're in yeah no that's like
an hour i think
53 minutes 53 minutes is the thing oh my
goodness i thought okay and the moves i
had were the moves that we were making
and fiddling with so after the move c3
wow
excuse me in bucharest yes ellie raza
was spending a lot of clock he was or an
18 year old now 19 year old one of the
things that i've always thought that
separate the extraordinary uh
generations of geniuses
was speed i mean vishy was on a war on a
planet of his own
karpov was a very very very fast player
he
slowed down considerably as he got older
you're not i'm not used to seeing
juniors uh
using all of their clock
yeah he's known as a fast player i know
obviously he has a lot of experience in
wrapping his legislation as we see our
schedule three rounds and a rest day
just to remind you that tomorrow is a
rest day tomorrow monday june 20th we
will have no round for you we need the
rest the players need the rest
yeah
these are long games and as we're
talking about a 53 minute thing it is
it is the longest thing of the day but
it's not even by much because hikaru
himself thought for 40 some minutes in
today's game as well
uh actually your car's only i had 10
minutes on the clock
um
but as you're saying yeah the youth is
usually known for their speed right and
i think
it
shows that the rest is maturity as a
player
that he slows down in positions that he
thinks are critical right and sometimes
he finds the correct solutions and of
course his chess is still very young he
still needs a lot of details here and
there on how to improve especially in
end games but i like that he's taking
this time i like that he is already
focusing on how to find the best move in
this long time controls instead of
relying completely on instinct exactly
there we see uh
earlier footage
yeah this is from
finishing a 50 score his games were
interesting the results weren't that
interesting yeah yeah he ended up losing
to his country man uh maxine bashar
lagraven he's a crucial game a crucial
game and his only win i believe came
with against dominguez
and that was a nice he did win against
dominguez but i thought he lost another
game outside of the one against mvl i
think he finished a minus one didn't he
you're right christian he did finish the
minus one he lost to someone else who
did he lose to
not
fabiano
yan maybe perhaps yes first round
was white he played a bishop's opening
right some great absolutely craziness in
the middle game and anjan took it yeah
absolutely right
nice yeah yeah he was winning he was
winning yeah
i was winning a wild game and then uh
jan nepo just turned it around and won
that game
started off slowly he wasn't uh in his
usual shape
and uh bounced back with an important
victory against lanier and everybody was
expecting that he's going to continue
uh he his ascent but he did not he lost
against mvl actually with the white
pieces as well so he lost two games with
the white pieces in that tournament
wow
yeah
and we know
we know that magnus uh has uh said it
publicly quite a few times that he wants
uh a new challenge a challenge from
this up and coming generation probably
he was referring to al
um what do you guys think do you guys
think magnus is going to defend his
title if somebody else outside the
valley reza wins the canvas
okay
all i can say is what magnus has been
saying i mean he doesn't play games he
yeah really
openly and truthfully about his plans
and uh he has had critics let's say in
the last round game in london against
fabiano he offered a draw in a position
we kind of felt that fabiano is white
was in trouble but his attitude was
i have a much better chance of retaining
my title in a tie break
than i do in this classical game i'm
gonna go to a tiebreak and he did and he
was successful
and throughout his whole career uh
even when he was signing the contract
for chennai in 2013 here in st louis
uh he really had issues he felt it was
unfair that he'd have to go to vichy's
hometown
he's he's the rookie it's his first
maiden voyage into the world
championship and played vichy at home
like is that is that right and uh let's
take a look at magnus
through the candidates of course he won
in 2013 by losing the final game
alejandro absolutely uh the spectacular
game or round i would say uh famously
peter spidler beat magnus carlsen with
the black pieces actually right but
kramnik also fell the sword of evancho
who had an atrocious tournament and
played
literally
right destroyed
and
uh
then after losing
the title in chennai we all thought well
vishy you know thank you you for all
your golden years you've done really
really well it was nice knowing you no
no he comes back and decisively wins the
2014 candidates but unfortunately for
fishy fans he lost yet again in a world
championship man that one is sochi and
in 2016 we were at that tournament i
last round the last round gave a rook to
bobby
and it was it was brilliant it was a
brilliant win by sergey karjakin he
really was um a great participant in
that in that candidates he started
slowly and then he bounced back that
beautiful win against bobby really
cemented what was a good tournament
yesterday and of course remember that
fabian sergey went into the last round
equal amount of points but back then
unlike this tournament the tournament
had a mathematical thigh break which was
favoring sergey at that point so fabi
knew he couldn't buy yeah
and he had an amazing year he barely
lost the magnus in the world
championship exactly in the new york
world championship match it was all tied
up and once again a tie break win for
magnus then 2018 yeah 2018.
what a great start he had in that
tournament beating wesley in the first
round
in berlin in berlin yes and in the third
round beating kramnik uh with the black
pieces from a lost position
this it was an incredible year for him
as well and that uh of course that match
also went all the way to tybrix as you
were mentioning yes sir and of course
the next one is the winner of the 2020
2021 candidates tournament the one that
was postponed for a full year yandere
pontiac really head and shoulders above
the crowd to the point that he won this
event full round to spare indeed he lost
his last round game against ding
laren but it wasn't enough as he won and
challenged magnus he made it a match
there was a match of two halves the
first half was very very very
competitive the second half it was
magnus all by himself yeah this didn't
feel like anybody was sat in front of
him as bangladesh just steamrolled nepo
over and over again but the question
that was asked to us
is who would be magnus's
uh toughest
opponent i i'm tempted to say fabi but
go for it
i would say that favi is definitely up
there from the from the eighth we have
here i i know he's having a bad
tournament and he does seem to be
sharing levon's curse on the candidates
but dingleran has been touted as one of
the top players to fight against magnus
for many reasons first of all uh a
different style of chess incredibly
solid incredible preparation uh he has a
federation that is going to be
supporting him absolutely and completely
anything that you need he will be given
right and um
and he just had the ex he has the
experience he has been number two slash
three in the world uh he has played in
the candidates before he's played the
candidates before it's hard to come up
with somebody that is not thing loretta
i mean the guy's 2800 and he hasn't it's
not like he just got 2800. he's been
2800 for a while he's been there and you
you said something that was really
important in that whole government the
chinese chess federation is backing him
with everything they've got you've heard
from richard report saying yeah you know
like
my hungarian chess federation they don't
even know i exist yeah
very very different uh
sponsorship
and we have a question from our audience
oh thanks for joining uh the chat
why does the current
champion not have to compete wow
i couldn't say any better than myself no
the sport does this rafa doesn't have to
play
good point no no seriously thank you for
the question
uh there are other sports of course
boxing uh boxing is the one that we
always come up against the champion is
waiting for a challenger or whether
you're in the heavyweights or whatever
so but
right and that is one of the complaints
that magnus has
you organize these marvelous tournaments
as candidates in madrid and the world
champion doesn't play so here's the
organizer putting incredible sponsorship
incredible
heart and soul if you will into the
event
and then the
champion magnus is just waiting two
years for this cycle to be completed and
in fact magnus has played in the world
cup
this 128 player knockout event because
he likes the event he thinks it's really
wonderful even though it's a
qualification event
for finding a challenger which itself
has some
you know yeah
right it has some issues because we
actually had to determine um who was
third in the world cup so we we have to
forgive me it's a it's a bit of a
lengthy explanation but we really have
to go back to about 1948 alec well
alekan has passed away with the world
championship match with the world
championship title
b-day takes over the the
running of the world championship title
and they do this 1948 quadruple
round robin which michael bovinick wins
then the feed a cycle was really set up
in my opinion
as a cycle that favored the soviet
players
this is the way that the soviet union
dominated shas
by dominating the fide cycle and this
idea that the world champion whether it
be bobbinic or whether it be tall
is waiting for his challenger and bobby
fischer
yeah please sorry to interrupt you uh
quick update fabiano coroner has drawn
his game again
um
wow continue so i just got to say the
history of the um
world chess championship has been one
that's favored
the reigning world champion and the
history goes back many many decades
there's no i think for me there's no
other way to put it it's just an archaic
system that we've had trouble booting uh
getting rid of getting rid of because
it's such a fun system when you think
about it for spectators and it's a
really good system for fide because you
get to organize the candidates and
everybody wants to watch the candidates
when you think about it organize the
world championship everybody wants to
watch the world championship and that's
great and we've had it for so long that
it feels like part of us what is our
golden event the world championship is
the crown jewel it's our crown jewel and
getting rid of it uh would mean changing
the format entirely now why doesn't the
champion start from ground zero
that's a different question and i think
that one comes back to just
what you said i mean i think that if
they stripped
this right of the
of the world champion
to yeah exactly the world champion to
defend yeah right if they just tripped
him of that right and they said the top
two of the candidates go and play the
match yeah i don't think that much
changes i think it would be a great
system i think it would actually be a
big improvement
hard disagree with you guys it loses its
whole uh prestige the world championship
match loses his whole procedure
because the champion is the champion you
have to prove yourself that you are a
worthy challenger and you go through all
these trials and tribulations to get to
the champion it happens in boxing
tennis is not really a great example
because you don't have a tennis world
championship at least not to my
knowledge right you just have the right
grand slam right there
but you have a lot of that no no no
there's a final there's a tournament
called the finals of the translation
exactly you have to qualify so it's like
okay so that's the world championship
you see i'm not that knowledgeable about
tennis in in in that regard but still i
i don't like it i like the similarity
with boxing the the champion in boxing
waits for a challenger and only when
they see a fifth challenger that's when
they will uh accept the challenge and
maybe we can change that so for example
you have magnus carlsen as the world
champion and then he sees firuja surging
through the rankings and then we set up
a match between him and perusia but that
i don't know first of all i'm going to
choose the challenger as the world
champion i hate that system because you
start choosing people and when the
moment you start choosing anybody i mean
this is just prone to corruption it's
prone to so many others but you also
choose it based on popularity and based
on what people want to see
but
okay
here check this one out
so bobby fisher
forfeits his world championship title in
1975 and he says i want a system where
the first guy who wins 10 games draws
don't count
well all the players would go into a
mental hospital i mean you know like a
30 game 60 game match no that's not
going to work
but i always thought what was a really
simple i don't have any problems with
this
system was you play all of these
tournaments of grand chess tour all of
these wonderful things and at the end of
the year number one plays number two a
match
and it's that simple and if the world
champion of the previous year
he falls down on the ranking list and
he's not number two well that's sport
i don't disagree it's a simple system
yeah it is a simple system
for us specifically uh i don't like the
comparison to boxing
because uh i don't i'm not incredibly
familiar with the boxing world but i i
know that there isn't like a
qualification cycle whereas we have a
grueling cycle it's not it's not a small
scale
i mean yes we do you guys watching us
you're in the candidates but this cycle
started about a year and three months
ago in a cycle that even i participated
in
where you play a qualifier
to your continental and from the
continental you qualify to the world cup
and from the world cup you qualify it's
not an easy process and that's why the
world championship is such a prestigious
title once you get it you get to rest a
little bit you went through this whole
cycle now you get the rest it matters
right
first of all we do have world
championships that reset we have the
rapid world championship that resets
every single year oh yeah and we have
the blitz world championships
that reset every year and we get
new world champions it's not as
prestigious as the classical world
championship and i want to keep that
tradition alive but i would argue
that in that particular case christian
and i know the point you're making
absolutely
is the blitz and the rapid are both a
swiss tournament
and it's over rather quickly it's five
days in fact for both of those world
championships and so it loses a lot of
its prestige by the fact that it's such
a short period now if you were to
take of blitz
events
and turn it into a five-day event that
would feature six game matches sure
where mbl and uh vikaru and magnus would
be playing
game matches in a single day and then do
you have candidates for the blitz as
well i don't know but i'm like how do
you think about that
as a way of making it more of a
prestigious event
but i do say this that once again
magnus has complained and he's been very
very vocal that he wants the system to
become much more modern
and he doesn't uh well he's getting
tired of these world championship match
does that simply exhaust him and he's
looking for
something else
i would not be surprised
if
fabi if nepo were to win at this
particular event and magnus says uh i'll
see you guys at the blitz yep see you
there
it might happen right it really might
happen especially with those two players
what would happen it would be the top
two
uh of these players who play a match and
for those of you who are just joining us
we have one game remaining as this looks
to be the first day that we have all
four draws yep so far it looks
impossible for our alerts to make any
progress we do have a couple of them and
the draw has been agreed actually oh no
no not yet sorry we have a couple of
moves in the alley rs against the car
game so we might as well update the
board it is more or less along the lines
of what we expected not exactly but more
or less along the lines he took on c3
did alireza i'm sorry it was the game it
was dude's game finished
i apologize and that was a draw three
draws in the books please yeah and this
is the current position after the move
uh b takes e3 knight takes c3 king c2
knight d5 and lareza going again on
another long think trying to somehow
maneuver his bishop uh
to now do a check
now down to
a half an hour differently 34 minutes
yeah wow okay
it doesn't obviously matter too much
because
black
black's not yeah black wants to play e5
black doesn't mind playing b4 as well
but essentially uh it's all about
getting this bishop on the long diagonal
and it doesn't seem like
white has a convenient way of doing that
if he if he goes in the very direct fl
fashion of bishop h4 e5 bishop to g3 the
move knight f4
is actually turning the tables to quite
a degree we're threatening to take on g6
this is actually a losing
kingdom pawn end game
for white as before
uh will
will give black the win so
he's having trouble getting
finding a way finding a path to the long
diagonal and the reason that he's having
trouble is because it doesn't exist it
doesn't exist boy talk about beating
your head against the wall because
he achieved so much i mean uh if you
think about the opening and what he was
trying to achieve from the opening this
is his like zenith that he could i i
can't imagine why getting any more from
than this position out of the opening
and it's not enough it's not enough it's
just like you have to say kudos to
chicago what a great defense an
absolutely masterful defense in this
game this is highly speak uh he gets in
trouble from the opening not exactly in
trouble but you know he feels under
pressure because the point out prepared
him has better ideas deeper ideas but he
sits down thinks forever calculates his
way out of trouble
and
through a little bit of magic because
they require quite a bit of magic this
somehow is a draw yeah tenacity tenacity
exactly wow wow and again let's just uh
recap because i didn't see when they did
make the draw and that was between um
uh duda and
fabi i actually thought fabi played
this very poorly i thought he got into
an ending that was going to be difficult
for him
and
not really
it turned out
that right around
these parts
is when i thought things were were
looking bleak
but
this was another one of those
i think
i mean how many people play the movie c5
i like c5 a lot actually
it's a great move let's see if it's a
great move i mean you just give away a
pawn in order to activate your pieces
you stop knight a3 it's very knight c3
knight a2 because you've got bishop c4
check
very clean that's a nice way of putting
it uh but you sacrifice the pawn for
activity
and
[Music]
another another
one the bishop e2
and look at this it's a lot of patience
from fabi to get to this position right
that's right he took the
the last pawn that he took was b4 which
is kind of funny
when you look at the position after the
move king c4 you told me the last pawn
that gets off the board this is the
before before our body be like i'm going
to take
h5 f7 and f5
before i delete before
now that's pretty funny uh
actually a very very uh hard fought game
and again another player duda he's gonna
go into the break thinking i've got
three draws
but opportunities
slipping yeah especially in the first
game when you think about where can do
the score that first game against
richard was
wow yeah where he was like crushing
position
you really expected him to bring bring
that point home it he slipped away
richard himself must be thinking well
i'm very lucky to have fifty percent
even though technically he was winning
against uh theresa yesterday yes the
other two games he was lost very very
shaky
yes and again we're uh we've got one
game remaining um
the number two seed
am i right ali amazon number two yes
and do we have opening moves uh today
yasser is
is that something did we do opening no
opening moves today yeah we made fun of
tom tom's
tom's feeling uh out of something they
got hurt yeah these feelings get hurt
easily easily right easily are they
brittle oh we have one i think we do
have one over a challenge to ourselves
can you
can you name this opening or not can you
name the opening
can you uh make the opening moves form
the name of the opening and
try
although i always felt this naming of
openings was a very uh
yeah it was a very western thing totally
wow wait a minute that's a simple one
it could not get any harder than this
queen's gambit accepted oh my gosh so
queen's gambit accepted is easy so we
make the opening move the queen pawn
move the pawn in front of the queen
advances
black does the same
then in order to get rid of this pawn or
at least to attack it we play c4 what is
known as the queen is gambit
and then black chooses not to defend his
pawn with e76 or c7 c6 that instead
captures the spawn on c4 and therefore
this opening is known as the queen's
gambit accepted and one i play a lot
brilliant thank you it's actually become
very popular to speak a little bit more
in depth at the opening it's it's
something that has surged it is it has
had an amazing revival in the last year
just a year i don't even say two years
where uh some some theories come out
some new ideas have come out for black
specifically in the e4 b5 variations and
uh
linear dominguez even maxim
graph a traditional groomfield player
has started taking up the queen's gambit
accepted as their way of equalizing with
black and right now it is uh quite
successful i have to say
no question about it and it's nice to
see it was actually
an open a defense i liked a lot uh
queen's gambit accepted in my opponent's
eye i i remember gary having a very very
difficult time uh trying to wrong-foot
me and the queen's gambit accepted he
did it so badly that he was worse after
like 12 moves with the white pieces this
was pretty funny the queen's gambit
accepted that is d4 d5
c4d
takes c4 uh back to hikaru for just a
moment because again um
ali reza is burning a lot of clock uh
christian
are there any traps
that he could
be well let's let's find them guys
because i'm not going to be able to find
anything with the engine the engine is
going to say zero zero well he's made a
move for the bishop g5 yeah hmg5 is what
we've been looking at for the last one
hour i think
i'm not exaggerating but that's right
it's not an exaggeration
there's only one logical move for black
here right and that is e5 you don't play
e5 i think you resign right okay so he
played it immediately i mean yeah yeah
okay so what if i just wait i just wait
your turn
uh so the idea is you can't move the
knight my goodness you move the knight
that's right resigns on the spot so now
i have a couple of options
k8 or b4 right i don't think you have a
couple of options i think you have to
play king h8
yeah b4 actually you take and then i
cannot take back because of bishop f6
okay king aj
king h8
you wait i wait
you wanna
triangulate you yes that's exactly right
i was going to triangulate
check this out guys isn't this like
aren't i like a genius uh i triangulate
does that help you at all i know and i
get the same position but now it's my
turn to play congratulations thank you
very much
uh
by the way when you get your king to c2
i might start thinking about
b4 because you will be able in that case
to be
captured back take it back with a check
with a check
yeah the desirable bishop c1 keeps
running into
either 97
or a knight
f4
and i'm not a happy camper i don't see
it uh
christian are are there traps so king to
c2 let's triangulate your wave um king
c1 king g87 king c2 now
does b4 actually work or do i have to go
king to h8 i think you have to go
well first of all i'd love for you to
refute king the h8 and by the way king
to d2 is on the board right now okay so
king to d2 we expect king to hit
immediately which came on the board
right now guitar sees it
and he just blitz
blitzes out his moves
okay
so again i i would love to chase this
night away if i could get this knight
out of dodge i will be able to play
bishop f6 and mate you so try it out
knight to f4 so now once you get the
knight to d3 i go knight before
once you once my king steps on this land
mine
d3 you get to play
okay so in that case if i go but let's
let's discuss that right
is that exactly the same position that
we have previously yeah it doesn't
doesn't matter i mean you're actually
you're technically down at tempo because
you haven't got an mb4 but it doesn't
matter for the races of the f pawn
exactly so you take on f4 take on f4
king to e4 and then you go b4 b4 and now
if i start by taking on f4 i'm just
simply not in time so take on f4 take on
a3
king g5 a2 or kg7 you have king g7 but
you can also go a2 because after king h6
a1 you actually control g7
yeah that's just winning
no i i don't think any of the pundering
games are they're not even draws
right
[Music]
yes
oh boy oh boy oh boy okay so i don't i
don't step onto the d3 square uh
christian we're gonna go king
e1 very clever i'm gonna i'm gonna roll
my king
up f2 f3 e4 by way
i am assuming a3
is a pardon me b4 is your id yeah let's
go wait we yes do you want to play b4 b4
and a3 well
then in this case finally my bishop
actually has a a decent job and i can't
believe it
it's not a four knight f4
well
how fast or not is it it's fast enough
we've already calculated this
i think we have yeah knight takes g6 you
go you go back to but you don't because
i take on a3
don't go back anywhere
your knight is dominated oh my knight is
dominated in this particular version
yeah i don't get back wait how do we get
here
uh i think we should have thrown in a
no but you don't have to go knight f4
you can take on b4 because bishop a3 is
met with knight c2
well
wow so you can do this first if you go
to what you want well
how
how are you avoiding getting checkmated
here that's a 95 back and then i get
knight f4
you can take on a3 that's fine but
you're not in time disgusting i get
knight four this is totally disgusting
this is like a study
this is really bad 95. still 95. yeah i
just got 95. no no no this might be
losing actually
because i go bishop b2
right now nothing stops metaphor
uh just as hard feels very hard
my brain hurts
uh
and that is why
we
thought that ikaru is actually
drawing
this most difficult of endings uh by a
tempo
at each and every crucial moment
incredible that this is a draw but
hikaru calculating it accurately and
he's confident he blitzes out his moves
when he knows that he has done the work
the work is done he's done the
calculation he's not worried about the
position on the board anymore and by the
way is this their first encounter yes
first encounter classical chess
wow i actually think it's their first
encounter over the board over no no no
no they played in in rapid uh world
championships and blitz world
championships
i i've seen firsthand beat ricardo in i
think it was a blitz world championship
you are not mistaken
just stop and think about that
people don't do that uh routinely i can
tell you um
again getting in the heads of uh the
players i think if hikaru draws this
game
he goes back to his room with the rest
day feeling incredibly good
oh yeah his result oh yeah it starts
with a loss he comes back with a
beautiful grind beautiful grind and
this one in particular is a beautiful
defense yeah it's a really really
beautiful defense i mean right getting
surprised from the opening doing so much
work over the board really putting it
all out there and finding a narrow path
towards drawing this game and that has
to feel great exactly yeah and going uh
even though it's only a 50 score it's
not like we're jumping up and down the i
guess it's a very good yeah it's a good
50 again
there's 50 percent
for hikaru the way that he got there and
there's 50 for richard right
different different 50
exactly exactly and there we have our
current standings with this one game
remaining as soon as hicara makes a draw
then
then these two players for ruja and
ikaru if they split the point they will
join
yon and richard and i mean it's amazing
uh
it feels like it's been a long event
already but it's only three rounds and
we have 11 more rounds to go that's a
full tournament yeah yeah
i'm gonna call in the next day we're
good we're getting uh we're getting an
espresso machine soon yeah exactly we've
got to invest in
in some serious coffee making yes
absolutely so what do we have we have
aliresa down to how many minutes at the
moment
because i'm seeing 30. this was this was
actually their game in rapid oh there we
go oh there you go this is the gaming
rapid we had it was not blitz it was
rapid this was the moment
that ali reza made his last move this is
uh from the world championship match
from the world championship uh rapping
in poland warsaw
this past uh december that's right
quite an interesting moment right i
forgot that
chess-based india where hikaru yeah yeah
he played the rapid but either he didn't
finish it or he didn't play the blitz i
forgot yeah because he caught covert and
he was quarantined for like two weeks
and you can't do it forever that was
terrible
poor guy was suffering yeah
wow
all right well and some uh questions
from the social thank you for joining
for joining us
it especially when
when we have uh alireza thinking for an
hour
uh from twitter users this grab a world
championship is an open event every year
i like to see it move to something more
like chess it was like much bigger
opportunity to promote the spectacle
casual i i disagree strongly with the
sentiment uh the open systems like an
open switch like an open swiss first of
all they're a little bit of a lottery
they really do feel like a little bit of
a lottery kind of by definition swiss
tournaments need to have one more white
than black you already are favoring nine
rounds 11 rounds whatever it is and the
reason it's an even number is that if
you get a 10 round swiss inevitably
somebody will instead of have five and
five will actually have two extra ones
so it's an even worse uh bias towards
them right and the other thing is that
the world championship for us is not
it's not an open it it's an invitation
of the best
possible the creme de la creme
each other every day i played oh so when
i was coming up there was really
actually two events and they weren't
that great they were the us
championships
and the us open and those were
two of the most prestigious event they
were run by the united states chess
federation and the difference or the
quality of play between the two
tournaments was night and day yes
because the open us open had 500 600 700
players it doesn't matter how many
players uh and walter brown might win
the us open by playing two very strong
players yeah versus a u.s championship
where he's playing strong players every
round yeah i actually played i actually
won the us open and the year that i
wanted i started with six out of six so
you can imagine yes exactly you can
imagine the type of tournament that is
completely different scenario right and
you need to score you know yeah yeah i
did i wanted an open i want to buy half
a point
it would be a six out of six start by
the way guys i think the tweet was
actually saying that they want to change
it towards what chess has
ah
from the open version towards chess has
in terms of matches because it's um
let's do it again for marketing let's
see if we can read i'd love to see it
move to something more like chess
reading comprehension uh i had this
happen to me the other day it was really
sad so fabi texts me and he says my
party would like to join uh
yourself and uh
yes i was part of that
we were we were all there
to have a party don't lie to us yeah i
miss red first of all there's a lot of
lies there were a lot of lies in a very
short amount of time first of all
you don't text
no that's not exactly it was an email
and i'm thinking he's having a party and
we'd like to invite you oh thank you
very much no fabi i'm tired you guys
were all coming to crash exactly the
party was in our place exactly we're
inviting you to open the door exactly
and then the next thing i know uh lavon
is hosting i mean he was living above me
at the time so yeah uh we have more
moves yes we're going straight down the
line that we just saw g5 e5 king d2 king
h8 king e1
oops
king e1 yes
okay the line that we looked at sorry b4
is on the board i
you can still play whatever you want
this white i guess uh by the way how's
how do you make a draft for bishop c1
how do i make a draw after bishop c i'm
assuming i'm playing this knight f4
business
but right thought you weren't on time on
some of this i'm threatening knight d3
check aren't they or knight takes g6 as
well
you take on uh b4 let's just support
yeah yeah just for fun because we're
fine because i'm i don't want i don't
want to calculate it knife d3 with my
king on h8 however
i don't think i want to get into these
endings do i probably not right and i
probably would hide my king on f1
oh you just do this yeah yeah never mind
this is lost how did you guys get to
this
i played bishop c1 right away he
actually took on b4 by the way uh
they're going straight into the line
that we discussed yeah a takes b4 was
played instead uh bishop c1 you got a3
on the board yeah yeah you wanted knight
takes b4 right
okay this is going to peter out into a
draw very fast very very fast right
there's only one move he's already taken
king e2
uh knight d5 back bishop takes a3 knight
f4 and you sign the scoresheets yeah you
can even take on a3
uh which line did you say
i i mean i don't know i think it doesn't
matter right everything's a drug
right king e2 okay can you do knight d5
back
because
because you're threatening knight f4
there's no way to stop it bishop takes a
three knight f4 check and you pick up
the phone pick up the pawn
wow well
uh again uh you know fighting chess
hard fought games at all of these games
okay i'm not going to say anything about
timor's game today because it really
really did feel like he came uh
with an empty tank
from yesterday right yeah he just he was
not ready to play a uh candidate's type
of game against nepo and that game was
actually a tame draw compared to what
we've been seeing in all of these other
games
uh including this game with vicar let me
just refresh my board for just a second
so i'm up to date with the players we
have bishop c1
knight takes b4
uh on the board
again the desirable bishop takes a3 is
going to be my knight c2 check that'll
hurt your feelings or 93. i don't think
they change i think it's even a draw
both ways
really losing the bishop and yeah and
then what i don't know
what i put my king on e4 what you need
to get
[Music]
knight d5 with the dual
ideas of knight f4 knight e7 just going
after the g6 pawn and he played it is uh
enough for the draw he played it bishop
takes a three what an incredible save
this really does feel like a study right
yeah that's just incredible and it all
stems from that moment where we were
wondering why is he car just simply not
playing a4 yeah he was calculating all
this very difficult decision and he only
had a couple of minutes left on his
clock if i'm not mistaken
yeah okay so all right so we have a draw
guys we have a draw officially between
hikaru nakamura and alireza furuja what
a game this is exactly what we wanted to
see from this fight alireza brings the
novelty brings the idea brings the fire
hikaru sits down extinguishes it with
incredible calculation i mean kudos to
hikaru what a great game by him this is
very impressive truly and uh when i
think about what ali raza played this
whole queen c4 to a4 to c2
and to follow it up
with um queen c1 yeah but let's look at
the standings first as we have faviano
carolina well nothing's changed
yeah they sit at the top of the score
with a plus one on 50 we have young
staff duda richard rapport for ruja and
now hikaru nakamura as well and with
minus one we still have teemu rajabov
and ending liran
indeed
and this is where we were saying that uh
farouja played an extraordinary
for me on
idea
this whole piece sacrifice and this
wow i mean with everything
hanging on d4 e4
ideas of e5 you've got all of these
opportunities queen c1 incredible really
incredible stuff
and
you know
wow
and then you're sitting there telling me
that you know what yes sir i actually
prepped
this and it wasn't a surprise for you
this idea that ali
raza un corked and that really put
hikaru on a back foot i don't know
exactly how much time he spent but i
believe is like a 40 45 minute thank you
yeah
to to navigate his way through the
complications he did it successfully
well done well done to hikaru and uh uh
uh great this is the kind of split point
we want to see right if you're gonna
have a draw this is it yeah full of
content full of content this is
absolutely great game you look at the
candidates games
yeah this is exactly what you want to
rescue exactly it's a great game
you couldn't set it better
well as we get ready to round up our
coverage once again we have to remind
you tomorrow is a free day we will not
be on air
and uh christian your final thoughts
after these three very hard-fought
rounds
three very hard fought rounds and at
some point it was bound to happen we had
a lot of decisive games in each the
first and the second round but uh
finally we have around with four draws
but three of them were extremely
combative one of the players that's
definitely going into the rest day with
a sour taste in his mouth must be ding
lyran who unfortunately today was unable
to crack richie rapport's defense while
he will have to return after the rest
day with new powers it's going to be an
amazing event an amazing fourth round
tomorrow we get to rest and we'll resume
in a couple of days
thank you christian
and let's take a look at our predictions
uh oh nothing's changed from yesterday
because we have four drops
uh but again kudos to our friend
maurice ashley for joining us from
druid thank you for uh
jumping on the stream with us and
for that matter
some gm's whether they're from the st
louis university
mizzou uh
tigers uh we're we're we're happy to
host you and your thoughts on the skype
absolutely so we'll have plenty of
guests for you starting on tuesday so
join us then as we have round four of
the candidates for now we'll say goodbye
we're going to enjoy our rest day
ourselves see you then good night
everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you